Okay, the State Board will come to order and convene.
We're going to have as our first item of business a closed session.
So now that you're all seated and this is always awkward, we need to ask you to leave.
And so the Board will be moving to closed session to discuss or take action on the following cases.
MSC, CAPEEM versus Torlakson,
and California School Boards Association versus the State Board of Education, the Aspire litigation.
So if we could clear the room and the board, we'll then go into executive session and talk with our legal team.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene and we will hear at this point item 18, which is the proposed formation of a new unified school district from the Huron portion of the Coalinga-Huron Unified School District in Fresno County.
And
Before we begin, I'm going to announce in closed session the board discussed and or took action on the following cases, MSC, CAPPEM versus Torlakson and CSBA versus SBE, the Aspire case.
So, Larry Shirey is here to present the item and then we'll have board member technical questions and then we'll have our public hearing and go from there.
Go ahead.
Okay, I think we've got a PowerPoint.
I don't know if it's up right now.
It's right there in front of us.
Good morning, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, board members.
Mike.
Is it on?
Yes.
Okay, I just wasn't close enough.
I'm Larry Shirey, School Fiscal Services Division.
This morning, we have a petition to form a new unified school district from the Huron portion of the Coalinga-Huron Unified School District in Fresno County.
As the name suggests, the Coalinga-Huron District serves students from two communities in Fresno County, Coalinga and Huron.
The petition was signed by 25% of the voters in the Huron community.
They have a number of reasons for wanting to break away and form their own new district.
One is the belief that the Huron community is very different and separate from the Coalinga community.
They're more real, they're more rural in nature, less affluent, and more heavily minority.
The distance, another issue is that the distance that high school students have to
take a trip on the bus to the high school.
There's only one high school in Coalinga, Huron.
It's in Coalinga, so Huron students have to, and it's about 20 miles away from the city of Huron.
So petitioners are concerned about the bus ride of about 300 students from Huron that go to the high school.
They say that bus ride can take up to an hour one way.
And finally, the way the governing board for Koalinga Huron is elected is by two trustee areas.
There are three trustee areas, three trustees from the Koalinga area and two from the Huron community.
The Huron community feels that with that minority representation on the board, that they are, they sometimes, their needs are not represented by board decisions.
So those are, I mean, there are some other reasons, but those are the three primary reasons why the community is seeking to form its own school district.
The county superintendent determined that the petition was sufficient and transmitted it to the Fresno County Committee.
Just a quick note on the Fresno County Committee.
Most county committees in the state have had their authority transferred to the County Board of Education.
In Fresno County, as with most larger counties in the state, there still is a separate county committee.
It's an 11-member body.
Two members from each county supervisorial district and one member at large.
The county committee is elected by board members from all the school districts in the county.
The County Committee conducted two public hearings on the petition.
Staff from the Fresno County Superintendent's Office performed and prepared a review of the nine minimum threshold conditions.
And we'll talk more about those conditions in a moment.
The County Committee found that four of those minimum threshold standards were not met and subsequently recommended that the State Board disapprove the proposal.
This is a visual depiction of the area.
As you can see, the whole of the Coalinga-Huron district is not portrayed here to the west and the north.
There is considerable Mount Diablo mountain range.
We're not showing that just to provide a little more clarity.
Highway 5 runs from northwest to southeast right through the center.
of the map, the Huron community is in gold to the east and the Coalinga community is in green to the west.
And the solid black line that starts from the top in the upper left-hand corner is the proposed boundary, the proposed split of the district into Coalinga and Huron.
Excuse me?
Yeah, we're not getting colors, are we?
Oh, you're not?
So these green areas here are incorporated Coalinga.
This gold area here is Huron.
This is the boundary of the Unified School District.
This is Highway 5 running down through the district.
And this solid black line is the boundary that the Huron petition is proposing be the dividing line between a Huron portion
a Huron Unified School District and a Coalinga Unified School District.
Okay, thanks.
That's clear.
Now, let me just stay here for a couple more minutes.
There are some concerns about this boundary on the Coalinga side.
The City Council is concerned.
Coalinga City Council is concerned because, you know, it incorporates, it takes in some of the Coalinga territory, city territory.
It moves very close to the city's sphere of influence.
The Koalinga Huron School District is concerned because, you know, these areas here are all oil fields, very, you know, high assessed valuation.
So they're concerned that the boundaries are taking a disproportionate percentage of the assessed valuation of the district.
This is a depiction of the student, proposed student population of the two districts.
You know, we're looking at the elementary, middle and high school levels.
Just as a note, we're not including the 93 students who are in the continuation high schools and special day, just for clarity purposes.
Coalinga-Huron currently has about 4,400 students.
proposed district, you can see the splits down there, it's about 30, 38, 39 percent of the total Coalinga-Huron school district would be in the Huron, a new Huron district in the remainder, in the remaining portion of Coalinga.
So here's what we're going to do today.
I'll present the CDE's findings on the nine minimum standards
As I relate to the proposal, and again, these are minimum threshold conditions that the Education Code establishes.
However, the Education Code does provide the State Board with considerable flexibility in handling these things.
You can, even if you find them not met,
any one of the conditions not met, you can still move the proposal forward because you can determine that the exceptional circumstance applies or the conditions can't literally be applied to this particular reorganization.
After I've finished with the presentation, you hold a public hearing.
Let me move ahead.
And then you'll take action.
after you've heard public comment.
Now, you cannot approve the proposal today.
This is a project under the California Environmental Quality Act.
That needs to be satisfied before you can approve the project.
What you can do is you can disapprove it or you can find that there's a compelling reason or it has merit and move it forward.
And moving forward means that we'll send it back to the local level to comply with CEQA.
And then once that's taken care of, it'll come back to the state board for final action.
So again, in summary, your choices are going to be disapprove or consider it has merit and send it back for further action.
Okay, now on to the nine minimum standards.
Four of the conditions didn't have any significant, really significant local concerns when locally or in our opinion.
One is that the district will be of adequate size.
The regulations that the state board has adopted tell you that a unified district needs to be 1,501 students.
It meets that condition.
that there's a substantial community identity in the reorganization, you know, with the Huron and Koalinga split, you know, everyone believes that that community identity condition is met.
There will be no significant increases in cost to the state.
You know, this is really kind of a condition that doesn't, not a lot of things increase cost to state, unless you're dealing with basic aid districts or necessary small school funding.
So, everyone believes that that condition is met.
and it's not designed to increase property values.
This is usually a condition that's applied to territory transfers when you're moving from one district to a district that's perceived to be more affluent.
So, that doesn't really apply much here.
We agree with the county committee that all these conditions are substantially met.
Now, the next condition we're going to talk about is the division of assets.
Whenever a district
is split, as is proposed in this case, there has to be a plan to divide the assets of, in this case, the Coal Inca Huron School District.
The Fresno County Committee found this condition met, but there were some local concerns that were raised around this condition, and I just want to briefly touch on those.
The Education Code establishes standards or default methods to divide
various assets and obligations of a district when it's reorganized.
It also provides that the State Board of Education has considerable flexibility in terms of adjusting those default standards.
If you find that there would be a more equitable way to do that.
So keep that in mind as we go through all the conditions and especially this one.
The first issue we have is that the
Huron petitioners believe that they should have access to a proportionate share of the unissued or the approved but unissued bond funds of the Cole and Gaheron District.
Whenever a bond measure is approved, you establish a bond cap, which in statute is defined as two and a half percent of the assessed valuation.
That's kind of like the credit limit on your credit card.
And then when
the district, you know, the voters have approved that bond limit, but then when the district issues or sells a bond issue, that becomes like, that becomes debt, a bond in a debtor's, it's like debt on your credit card, a charge on your credit card.
So we're going to talk about how the debt part should be divided in a moment, but right now let's just talk about that remaining credit limit that the coal indicator on district would have.
The Fresno County Committee does not find any support in the Education Code to divide the credit limit, divide the approved but unissued bonds.
We agree with that.
There is no standard set in the Education Code how to divide that as there is with other assets and obligations.
There is no authority in the Education Code for the State Board to find some other equitable way to divide this and there is no
approval or no standard in the code to allow such a division to be part of the plans and recommendations of a reorganization proposal.
So it's our opinion that all of the unissued bond funds would remain with the remaining Koolinga Huron School District.
The second issue, and again we're going to provide a little more clarity, is the issue of how to divide
the debt that the district does have, the bonded indebtedness.
The Education Code provides a standard.
It says that any district pulling away, in this case the Huron district, would be liable for the greater of the amount of bond funds that were spent on facilities that exist in the Huron community or
the proportionate share of bonded indebtedness based on the assessed valuation.
So, if they're pulling, in this case, 59% of the assessed valuation out of Coalinga-Huron, that's going to be the greater under the Education Code.
Therefore, the Huron District would be responsible for 59% of the outstanding bonded indebtedness
They write, they will have about 38% of the kids and about 59% of the assessed valuation, therefore 59% of the bond.
Now the petitioners, as I mentioned before, you have authority to propose a more equitable distribution if you think it's warranted.
The petitioners, as I'm sure they will tell you, think that that's warranted.
We disagree for three reasons.
Number one is that when you pull out so much bonded indebtedness from the remaining Koalinga school district, then what's going to happen with that portion, that new district or that reorganized district, is that the amount of bond debt they have is going to exceed their bond cap.
So they're going to have difficulty
accessing bond funds to address future issues.
Now, of course, you know that they could submit a waiver and get that bond cap raised, but there's some other concerns with that because it's also going to affect what the voters, what the property owners in the district have to pay in property taxes.
And that's our second issue.
If the bond, the assessed valuation is the lifeblood of funding facilities in the school district.
If you pull a disproportionate amount of assessed valuation out of the district, that means that you're taking away from the remaining Coalinga district, Coalinga-Huron district, the Coalinga portion, the ability to pay for existing bond debt.
which means property taxes are going to go up significantly on the remaining property owners in the Coalinga area.
So, that can create a couple of problems.
One, it could, if it goes up too much, it might violate some of the issues that the voters approved in approving the bond.
And it also would make us have to consider what the voting area is going to be at this proposal.
The default voting area would be
if you approve it and if it goes back to the county for a vote would just be the Huron community.
But if there's going to be a significant effect on property owners in the Coalinga, the remaining portion of the district in the Coalinga portion, then we would have to consider what that effect is.
It may cause us to recommend and you to expand the election area to include the whole Coalinga Huron school district.
The third issue is that
the Huron students use more than just the facilities that are in Huron and specifically the Koalinga High School.
And they will continue to use the high school for up to five years after if they were to form as a new district while they build their own high school district.
So they are deriving, they would, they are and they would continue to derive a benefit from the Koalinga High School.
And a significant portion of the bond funds
used by Cole and Gaheron have been used for the high school.
Are we still on?
OK.
I think I've lost it here.
There it is.
Now we're going to turn our attention to, so in summary, the Fresno County Committee found this division of asset conditions substantially met.
We agree as long as the standard in the Education Code for dividing bonded indebtedness are used.
If the State Board should consider another method of dividing the bonded indebtedness, then we might have to reconsider what our recommendation is in this condition.
Now, we're going to move to the three other conditions.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, never mind.
Now, we're going to move to the four remaining conditions.
The first one is the issue of preserving the ability to educate students in an integrated environment.
Koalinga-Huron currently is a heavily minority district, 89.5%.
We're not going to focus much on the elementary and middle school populations here because their populations are not going to change as a result of the reorganization.
The elementary schools in Huron currently serve the students in Huron, the elementary schools in Coalinga and the middle schools currently serve the students in Coalinga.
The issue that we have is with Coalinga High School, which currently is about 88.5% minority.
The proposed reorganization would move those percentages as portrayed on the screen.
A proposed Huron High School would be pretty much 100% minority.
Currently, right now, there is only one non-minority student at Coalinga High School from the Huron community.
The remaining Coalinga High School would be about 82%, about a 16.5% drop, percentage point drop.
So, we're recommending this condition is not substantially met because it inhibits the ability of the districts to ensure that students are integrated or educated in an integrated environment.
Now, there are a number of other issues that you can look at here and that we talked about in our report.
One is that the situation currently exists with the elementary and middle schools.
in Kualinga and Huron.
There's no moving students from Huron to Kualinga or vice versa.
So the student population in Kualinga reflects the population, the general population of Kualinga, and the same for the Huron area.
Can you be more specific what you mean by minority?
Because it could be, I know the ethnic student subgroups, but I'm trying to really paint a picture as to why this proposal and why folks feel underrepresented.
So I'm thinking of the great divide between Watts and Southgate down in Los Angeles, where now both communities are predominantly Latino, but they still feel very different.
So when we're talking about minority, are we saying African-American, Latinos, or is it predominantly Latinos and still divisions within the Latino community?
Yeah, well, you know, our standard is that we need in this conditions that we need to look at all minority students compared to white students.
So in this particular case, in Coldinga, you know, the vast majority of minority students are Latino or Hispanic.
Is that the question?
I'm trying to figure out the demographic profile.
So is it 99.8% Latinos?
Is it 80% Latino and 10% African-American?
I don't have the numbers in front of me.
I think we put them in our report, but it's in the upper 80%.
Upper 80, 88 or so percent are Hispanic or Latino students.
So it's almost all the students, all the minority students.
If you want, I can go through the report and get the exact numbers.
But it's very, very predominantly Hispanic or Latino.
So, as I was saying, this condition that we are concerned about at the high school level currently exists at the elementary and middle schools.
You know, there have been no efforts by the district in the past to, you know, to adjust that.
But they do have the ability to do that based on the current arrangement.
They would lose that if the districts are separate.
Similarly, as most areas in the state, the minority, in this case Hispanic or Latino population, is increasing while the number of white students go down.
So the Cola Ninga Huron School District right now is becoming more minority.
And also there's the issue of the, you know, one of the things we look at is the feasibility of providing an integrated environment.
Right now it's happening because the students in Huron are being bused into Kualinga.
So, you know, that's, you might want to take that into consideration about, in terms of the busing and the busing time in terms of determining whether or not it's feasible to provide education in an integrated environment.
But anyway, we agree with the Fresno County Committee that this condition is not substantially met.
The next condition is that the proposal will continue to promote sound educational performance.
I'm going to break for a moment.
My allergies are killing me.
I'm going to put a throat lozenge in.
The Coalinga-Huron District is a lower performing district.
If you look at the five by five grid, you have the new accountability system.
You're going to see a lot of orange and red squares for both the district and the school level.
The district also has a very high percentage of disadvantaged students.
It kind of, it differs between Huron and the community.
And the Coalinga community is kind of reflected by what the concerns that the Huron community stated in their reasons for wanting to form their own new district, their own district, that they are a more, they are less affluent than the Coalinga area.
But the primary, and again, that there's really not going to be much change at the middle and the elementary school level here.
The primary issue is what happens with the high school and that was the concern that was stated at the local level and by the Fresno County Committee.
They found this condition not met because they believed that the reorganization would take a small high school and then form two smaller high schools.
And those two smaller high schools would not be able to provide the same level of educational program and activities as the larger Coaldinka High School.
You know, we're not in a position to speculate in terms of what kind of program a new Huron district would offer.
But what we did is try to take a look at some general issues related to schools, high schools that are similar to what a Huron high school might be.
Similar for us meant a high school that was between 400 and 500 students, was in a rural area and was not a charter high school.
So we did an online review of those schools, looking at SARCs and school websites and other objective
online websites and we found that the number and variety of courses offered by those high schools was very similar to what Koalinga High School offers.
They offer similar extracurricular activities, especially in terms of band and
and FFA and athletic issues.
All the schools we looked at could field both a varsity and junior varsity football team.
So that's kind of my standard for athletics.
Our opinion is that the enrollment levels would not prevent the reorganized high schools from offering numerous and diverse curricular and extracurricular options.
Therefore, we're breaking from the Fresno County Committee who found that this condition was not met and we believe that this condition is substantially met.
The next issue is the facility cost.
If Huron forms a new district, they have to build a high school.
And they have five years to build a high school.
If they don't get it done in five years, then it comes back to the state board and the state board either reverts them back, reverts the whole, the two districts back to a single Coalinga-Huron, or we'll give them more time to build a high school.
Our estimate based on what a 500 student high school would require and current school construction costs,
is that it would take $35 million to build a high school.
There are also going to be other facility needs in Huron.
They're going to need administration support, maintenance operation services.
They're going to have to address special education, alternative education issues.
Also, the elementary school in Huron is
uses a lot of portables is getting pretty close to capacity.
So if there is any future development, substantial or significant future development here on area, then they're likely going to need a new elementary school or at least some renovation and some additions to the existing elementary school.
The other issue that concerns us is the capacity of the current
capacity usage of the current Coalinga High School.
Currently, that high school is operating at about 61% capacity.
If you pull the students out, it's going to be operating at less than 40% capacity.
So what we see is a situation where you have a lot of surplus capacity in the district and a lot of cost to build a new high school.
when really, if you look at it in the terms of the Kuala Lunga Huron High School, there's no justification for building the high school, given the capacity of the existing Kuala Lunga High School.
And therefore, the condition which states that the cost, facilities cost, will be insignificant and incidental to the reorganization, that condition is not substantially met.
Now, we take that condition because the state board has the authority to say there are exceptional circumstances and this condition doesn't apply.
We take that condition another step because we want to look at what funds the Huron School District would have available if they were formed to build a high school.
And we find that they would have very limited available funding for facilities.
They would have a bonding capacity of $31.5 million.
But the liability for outstanding bond debtors that we talked about would reduce that bonding capacity by $13.5 million.
So they would be left with $18 million in bonding capacity.
Additionally, we have, as you know, there was a school bond approved by the California voters last November.
We don't know how much of that money is going to be available for the Huron District.
We can't speculate on that.
It's going to be at least three years until this new district could go online and start thinking about building a high school, given the fact that it has to, if you move it forward, it has to go through CEQA.
It has to come back here for review and there has to be an election.
So, the earliest that this new school district could form would be 2020, July 1st.
You know, so we think and we look at the surplus capacity issues.
We look at the significant increase in facility cost and the additional construction needs that are likely and the limited funding sources that have been identified.
And we find that this condition is not substantially met.
The next condition is the effect the reorganization would have on the fiscal status of the districts, both the remaining Coalinga district, portion of the district and a New Huron district.
The county committee found that this condition was not substantially met, primarily because creating a new district would cause new administrative costs.
They'd have to duplicate the administration, board, maintenance and operations, all of that stuff.
And they found that that additional cost for them was enough to find this condition not substantially met.
We take a slightly different approach.
You know, when we look at formations of new school districts, we don't automatically assume that additional cost means that it's a negative fiscal impact.
the governing board of a new district is going to have some opportunity to, you know, adjust budgets, etc.
So we do not consider additional cost as the primary or only reason to find that this condition is not substantially met.
Instead, what we did is we ran some funding scenarios based on 2015-16 and 2016-17 school year.
And we find that
under LCFF transition rules for calculating the funding, the New Huron School District would receive a lower proportionate share of the LCFF than you would think they should.
And that's because under transition funding rules, we can't touch categorical funding.
So it's about a three.
would stay completely with, all the categorical funding is going to stay completely with the remaining portion of Coalinga-Huron School District.
That's about a 3% reduction in funding.
So, in our scenario, in 2015-16, Huron District is deficit spending.
The remaining Coalinga District would be running a slight surplus.
The next year,
Deficit spending would increase in Huron and the district would not be able to meet its minimum reserve for economic uncertainties.
The remaining portion of Coalinga would also be deficit spending at this point.
And those fiscal concerns would be exacerbated by any additional expenses that the new district would incur for administrative structure, maintenance and operations and any other costs that would accrue from becoming a new school district.
So we agree with the County Committee.
that this condition is not substantially met.
So in summary, we find that three of the nine conditions are not substantially met.
It does not preserve the ability to educate students in an integrated environment.
School facility cost will not be insignificant and incidental.
They will be significant and primary to the reorganization.
And the other condition we find not met is that there'll be no substantial negative impact on the fiscal management or fiscal status of the districts.
So, our recommendations are that these three conditions are not met.
We don't find a compelling reason or exceptional circumstance to justify moving the proposal forward.
And we support the Fresno County's unanimous recommendation to disapprove this proposal.
So you'll hold a public hearing and then when you come back after the public hearing, if the state board agrees with our recommendations, you should disapprove the formation of the new unified school district.
If you disagree with our recommendations and you find that there's a compelling reason to move the unification forward, we will then transmit the proposal to Fresno County for CEQA compliance.
And that's it.
Now, I'm here to answer questions.
If you have questions now that you want to pose to me, I'd be happy to answer them.
Or you can wait until after the public hearing when you start discussing the issue.
So, I would like Board Member Holliday, if you want to speak now or wait till after, you're the liaison for this area.
Thank you.
I just had a couple of questions.
When you were speaking about the drive time, the busing from Huron over to Coalinga, I believe in prior conversations that we've had about this topic, you indicated that actually there are a number of students in the Huron proposed district.
who are closer to the current high school than other students within the Koalinga proposed.
Well, I think the issue we discussed was the geographic size of what the Huron School District could be and the uncertainty about where they would be able to build a high school in Huron.
So that given that the geographic, you know, it's I don't know how many miles it is from the east to the west, the west boundaries of the proposed Huron School District, but there's likely going to be transportation.
Cost and transportation of students in a district that that's that are similar to the transportation times that we have now and won't be as many students involved depending again depending on where they where the new district is able to build a build its high school, but Just the fact that the district is as large would be as large.
It's a large rural area and so
a large rural area, some students are going to have to continue to be bused to a Huron school.
And another clarification, when you're talking about the outstanding bond indebtedness, so there is currently, we're not talking about the new bond that they have not drawn from the line of credit, we're talking about existing bonds?
Well, we're talking about both.
You know, the Kohling-Huron district just passed a new
voters in the district just passed a new general obligation bond in November.
So the liability for outstanding bonded indebtedness refers to both the existing bond debt on the earlier bond issue, but also any bond debt that's incurred by the Koalinga-Huron Unified School District from this point on to when a Huron Unified District would be formed.
So we don't know what that might be, but... I remember Ortiz-Lacombe.
You know, I'm a little divided with this because I've seen this happen in other communities where you could be integrated but not integrated.
And when you're made to feel like a second class citizen in your own school, in your own community.
And even within the Latino community, we are very diverse, you know, it's by generation, it's by languages, by socioeconomic status.
So I understand why there's a push for this, because people want to have a sense of belonging and
and some sense of local control and dignity in their school sites.
But I've also seen how difficult it is once you really get to the logistics and the legal aspect of dividing a district.
And one of the things that has come up in the past, which I didn't see reflected here and I'm wondering,
is teachers.
So when you have a unified district and now you have to become two, there is an issue of where the teacher has tenure and who then has the pension liability of a teacher.
And it gets really costly for some districts.
So I know that that has stopped other districts from pursuing that option of breaking down a district.
Has that been considered here beyond the facilities, which I know that that sounds like very cost prohibited, but there's also the cost of teachers and where they will transfer to.
That's a big one in previous conversations with other districts.
Right.
And you're correct.
It is an issue, but we didn't address it here because everything affecting not just teachers, but classified staff is governed by education code.
In this case, the teachers in the Huron community
It would just be the elementary and middle school teachers.
They would have a choice to either stay with the Coalinga-Huron district or move to stay with their same schools in a new Huron district.
A lot of that decision is going to be based on what the teacher is believed to be the viability of the new district and what their salary schedule is going to be because they're not guaranteed the same salary schedule.
And so if that's the case, and this is maybe the issue you're dealing with, you'll see a large number of teachers in the Huron schools wanting to remain in the Koalinga Huron School District.
And what then happens is that there will be overstaffing at the remaining portion of Koalinga.
And, you know, the younger, less experienced teachers would be pushed out.
And it was likely that those teachers would be the ones or it could be likely that those teachers would be the one moving to the Huron schools.
So, yeah, there's no guarantee of salary.
It's going to be up to the governing board of the new district and whatever and whatever bargaining unit for the teachers in the new district happens to spring up to determine what the new salary schedule will be.
And I think those are some unintended consequences that people don't always consider because you could have your own sense of identity, have more local control, feel more represented, but you may be financially insolvent and have these issues that have not been previously considered.
And that's a great concern.
And one other teacher issue is that, you know, I believe that the Teachers Union of Coalinga, as well as the Classified Staff Bargaining Unit, don't support this reorganization.
Any other questions before we begin the public hearing?
Superintendent.
The election that occurred, what was the percentage passage and the amount and how did it break between the Huron portion and the Coalinga portion in terms of the voters support for the measure?
The bond?
Yes.
I don't have that with me right now.
I know that the Huron petitioners would state that the Huron community did not support the bond.
But I don't have those numbers in front of me.
Right.
OK.
Now we have a public hearing.
Each side has 10 minutes to present.
And I declare the public hearing open.
And so I will take first the Huron petitioners who support their new district.
And they have 10 minutes and then the opponents will have 10 minutes.
Pardon?
These are the people that want to form the new district.
No, the reverse.
The people that want to petition approved should go first.
Good morning, members of the board.
My name is Bonifacio Bonnie Garcia.
I am counsel for the petitioners with the law firm of Garcia Hernandez Sani.
We are a law firm with offices in San Diego, Glendale, and the Bay Area.
We have extensive experience representing school districts for the last 20 years.
A point of personal privilege is that I grew up in Huron.
I then went on to Loyola Marymount, and I'm a graduate of the Harvard Law School.
The problem is that when I was in sixth grade, my parents decided that there were no opportunities for us, given that we would have to go to Coalinga High School.
And we moved.
My father ran the theater, ran the gas station, had a hay business, was an established member of the community, uprooted the family and got out of Dodge to go become a parole in the San Fernando Valley.
And our life became a lot tougher because of the lack of an educational opportunity.
And nothing has changed.
The compelling reason for the reorganization of this district is the fact that not only is Coalinga High School a unified school district, Coalinga-Huron Unified School District, low performing, Coalinga High School is rated in the bottom 5% of school districts, of high school districts.
For decades, the district has made decisions to the detriment and the benefit
the detriment of Huron and the benefit of the Kalinga.
I just heard that there was excess capacity.
There would be even more excess capacity if this had gone through.
It isn't like all of a sudden the number of Huron kids just dropped on Kalinga and they had to build up.
This thing has been developing for a long time and it's a little awkward to say we made all the wrong choices and therefore we should be protected.
by building from our decisions to build in Coalinga and not build in Huron.
And that's why we can't separate.
But to get into more particulars with respect to the recommendations.
The county's recommendation and staff's recommendations.
are based on number one, not completing, not considering the entire law with respect to the DSEG issues and actually having some factual errors with respect to the bond and the facilities issues.
Very quickly, let's talk about the DSEG issues.
I believe, you know, a surface review of the numbers shows, yeah, that's right.
There are almost no, in fact I think there's one white student in Huron and all the white students are in Kalinga.
But the other factors that the law states is that you look at some other things.
One is isolation, the distance.
Now people say it's 20 miles on a school bus that has to make stops at other areas in the rural areas that are rather than three miles.
of Huron that turned that bus ride from a minimum of 45 minutes to 90 minutes.
So students are on the bus a long time, a minimum of an hour and a half to three hours every day just to go to high school.
And you know they have the saying about this, when you put a kid on the bus they don't necessarily get off.
And that means you have a large number of kids, and this is true in LA.
I used to represent LA Unified.
A large number of kids when you're in busing, just the hazards of busing result in lower attendance over time.
That by itself.
And Huron has suffered from that in a massive way.
Moreover, the bus schedules limit students' opportunities to participate fully in the life of the district.
No question about it.
When you add to that the fact that Huron has 25% of its population that doesn't have a car, they couldn't even get their kids there if they wanted to get them there themselves.
I haven't even started to deal with the issue of having members of the community in Huron being able to go address grievances and deal with their rights to participate in the process in Kalinga.
They even can't even get there.
So isolation, next.
Demographics are changing.
And that is, you wanted to know what the numbers were.
Within a few years, it's going to be a difference of, Huron will have something like 98.9% Latino, and Coalinga will be 91%.
So let me get this straight.
For the privilege, for the beneficial effects of having to rub elbows, or being able to rub elbows with the white community,
their educational rights are still continuing to be devastated.
Because the numbers, the outcomes are clear and undisputed.
I did not hear anybody saying that anybody from here was getting a good education.
I didn't even hear them say that they were getting a good education in Kalinga.
What I did hear, let me slow down.
So,
What is clear is that I believe, and I think the record demonstrates, they're not getting a free appropriate public education.
The numbers from the city council demonstrate, and again, I want to emphasize this, that when you look at the residents of Huron, the high school graduation rate is only 27%.
You've been given numbers that say that 73%, what a great number, of Coalinga high school graduates are, you know, that Latinos graduated raised 73%.
Wow, what about that other 27%?
But that's an average.
Huron makes 38%, 39%, maybe 40.
Once you start factoring that average, Huron's numbers come in a lot lower.
There's a lot of argument about like, well, what is the real rate?
Well, it's not 27% high school graduates from Coalinga, because that's just the residential rate.
It's not 73.
A study done by Dr. Cyril Lozano in UCLA in 2011 found that that rate was about 50% graduation rate.
The other thing to note is that all the continuation high schools or facilities are in Huron.
The other thing with respect to DSAG is that everything goes one way.
Coalinga isn't under a requirement to DSAG, but nobody goes sending white folk to Huron ever.
You have a great deal of leeway on this inequity, but the bottom line is that you're not required to continue to sacrifice
Latino educational opportunities in the name of diversity.
Next, with respect to the bond, very quickly, I know my time is flying.
There's an error.
Lozano-Smith was counsel for the petitioners and did an analysis and presented the position of Kalinga on what that split was.
This is the first time we have heard the 59% number.
Lozano-Smith's number, and you see it in an attachment to our brief that we submitted on Friday, is 43% of the assessed value would go to Huron, not 59.
And we don't know where that 59% number came from.
And we can't find it in any of the materials other than the 43% number.
Kalinga's own number is that out of the $2 billion plus in assessed value, $949 million would be Huron.
That's not 59%.
And that's the original sin on which this staff's analysis is based in terms of the ability to bond.
How much of the indebtedness that we would be responsible for in Huron.
43, not 59.
And it's an error.
It's an error, okay, that Kalinga, and it's a number of 43% is a number that Kalinga has admitted in their own papers.
So don't know about that.
Next, with respect to the cost of a $35 million high school.
You know, we've looked and again, we've presented comparisons at other high schools of similar situated rural areas to provide program, not 35 million, it's 22.
All that's, you know, he said, she said, or whatever.
But starting with the bottom line number is not 59%, it's 43.
And then again, we can start getting into bloody details in the weeds.
But again, that's the bottom line number.
And of course, you have discretion,
And if we're talking a little bit about the margins, you guys also have the ability to craft an equitable solution.
Because the other point that's been clear is that over the decades, Coalinga has taxed Huron for the benefit of Coalinga facilities.
The last bond, $11 million, $2 million ended up in Huron, $9 million ended up in Coalinga.
Next, with respect to the finances, the state's analysis, we don't disagree with how they got there, but they used a number of 1520 kids.
We don't know where that number came from.
Kalinga itself indicated that it was 1620.
The census says it's 1861.
Kalinga commissioned a study by a demographer in 2013, and that number was 1,751.
So that's an outside number, even from Kalinga's own folk.
1,751 is more than 200 more ADA.
That alone would make it financially sustainable for the long term.
Thank you very much.
Okay, now the people that support the CDE recommendation can come forward.
Good morning State Board, State Superintendent of Instructions.
Thank you for having me here today.
My name is Roger Campbell and I'm a board member for the Colinga-Huron Unified School District.
I'm also a 60 year part of Colinga-Huron Unified School District.
I started in 1956 as a first grade student and I've either been a student or an employee of the district for the length of that time.
I'm here joined today by Lisa Culberson, our board president, Margo Perkins and Maggie Hong, who are principal and vice principals at Colinga High School.
And our attorneys, Roberta Rowe and Ryan Tung.
For the last 60 years, the district has served the students of Klinger-Huron community, providing the students a quality education while creating a warm and welcoming atmosphere for all students of the community.
The district agrees with the findings of CDE and the Fresno County Committee on the petition should not be approved.
I am here today to respectfully highlight some additional information that the board may wish to consider about why the petitions have failed substantially
to meet the number of statutory conditions for the petition to be approved.
Before I begin, please also be aware that we received the petitioner's lengthy written comments on Monday.
Petitioners did not serve the district courtesy copy.
We were only notified by CDE that we have them.
With the time limit in mind today, I will focus on three conditions the CDE and County Committee both concluded were not met, as well as an additional condition that the County Committee concluded was not met.
First, the district agrees with the committee, the county committee, and the CDE that the petition has failed to meet criteria number four because the reorganization will not preserve each affected district's ability to educate students in an integrated environment and will promote racial and ethnic segregation.
A major catalyst of the reorganization petition is the establishment of a new high school in Huron.
Based on the 15-16 CALPADS information, the reorganization would promote racial segregation because it would result in a significant increase in the percentage of Hispanic students that would attend the proposed new high school.
As an example, if the segregation reorganization is passed, the estimated student population of the new high school in Huron would be 97% Hispanic, 0.2% White, 2.5% Asian, and 2.2% African-American.
As compared to the current composition of Kalinga High School, which is 85% Hispanic, 11.4% White, 1.6% Asian, and 0.9% African-American.
The 12% increase in
Hispanic population would result in a new high school in Huron with 423 Hispanic students, one white student, one African-American, and 11 Asian students.
A prime example of the reorganization would result in racial and ethnic segregation.
This clear racial and ethnic segregation would have the effect of preventing an integrated educational experience for the students who would attend the new high school in Huron.
Petitioner argues that a new high school would closely resemble the demographics of the city of Huron, and therefore the board should completely ignore the specific criteria.
we disagree.
The legislature was very clear in creating the criteria that reorganization should occur should not occur when one effect with with the student attending school is a more radically racially segregated environment, which is the precise case here today.
Next, I would like to turn to seventh criteria.
The district agrees with the Fresno County Committee and the CDAE
that this criteria is not met because of the reorganization will result in a significant and undeniable increase in student facilities.
Education Code Section 35780 allows newly organized district five years from the date of the reorganization becomes effective to provide the necessary school facilities.
However, there is no indication that Huron Unified School District will be able to complete the reconstruction of a new high school within those five years.
School construction is a very complicated process involving multiple state agencies.
For example, just site acquisition requires numerous studies and approval from CDE, the Department of Toxic Substances, and control in the City Planning Commission, among others.
Excuse me.
More importantly, it is unclear how the proposed Huron Unified School District will attain the necessary funding to building a high school within the five-year time frame.
The CTE estimates the construction of the high school will cost at least $35 million.
Please note that the petitioner's estimated cost of $22 million is both inaccurate and misleading.
Petitioners point to the construction of Harmony Magnet School as proof of their $22 million facility.
a $22 million estimate.
However, Harmony Magnet School is not a standalone facility, but rather share a significant amount of crucial facilities with the existing Strathmore High School.
The proposed year on high school would therefore cost significantly more than the $22 million proposed by the petitioners.
The CDE's estimate of $35 million is more accurate.
Petitioner stated that state funding would be available.
First and foremost, there is no guarantee that petitioner will be deemed eligible for state funding.
Even if the petitioner was deemed eligible for state funding, the most petition the petitioner would be eligible for is the estimated six million dollars for construction of new high school.
That's leaving the petition responsible raising nearly 30 million dollars.
Petitioners suggested they could pass a local bond measure.
However, the feasibility of a new locally approved bond is uncertain, especially considering the fact that such a bond has not yet been placed on a ballot.
And uncertainty, the uncertainty of passage and the tight five-year statutory frame is created by the new high school.
Assuming the sake, for the sake of argument, the petitioners were able to pass a bond,
they would be significantly short of money required to build such a high school.
The maximum amount they would be able to raise through bonds is $18 million according to CDE estimations, far short of the $35 million needed.
All the process of a new high school is long and costly.
Therefore, it is abundantly clear that the petition will result in a significant and undeniable increase in school facility costs with no indication that the petitioners will be able to complete and pay for such construction within the requisite five-year time period.
The reorganization will also have a real and a possible negative impact on the facilities remaining at Kalinga High School.
Next, I would like to turn to ninth criteria.
The district, again, agrees with the Fresno County Committee and the CDE.
The criteria is not met because the reorganization will fail to promote the fiscal management and will be a substantial negative effect on the fiscal status of the district.
I wanted to emphasize the financial projections highlighted in the CDE report.
To remind you, Mr. Juan Morales, Director of the School Facilities and Transportation Services Division, reviewed the finances of the district along with the calculations of LCFF revenue to see how the financials would look at the proposed Huron and proposed Colingus districts.
They had two districts been in existence during the 15-16 and the 16-17 school year.
The results showed that the 16-17, both the proposed
Huron District and Proposed Clinger District would suffer from deficit spending.
The Proposed Huron District would have deficit spending of $2 million while the Proposed Clinger District would have a deficit spending of $1.3 million.
We note that $2 million in deficit spending for Huron does not take into account the cost of duplication of administrative services that are necessary for the creation of a new school district or the cost of funding a $35 million high school.
The district's current administrative positions alone, defined for ease of reference as directors, assistants, superintendents, and superintendents, cost our district about $1.4 million for 15-16 and benefits.
The project deficit spending along with the cost of duplication administrative costs and the necessary costs in Newton High School are clear evidence that the proposed reorganization will fail to promote sound fiscal management and will have a substantial negative impact effect on the final fiscal status of a district.
Finally, I would like to turn to the sixth criteria.
The district agrees with Fresno County Committee that the petitioners have failed to meet the criteria six because
performance was significantly disrupted educational programs of the district.
If the reorganization petition is granted and approved, the new high school would be established in Huron.
The current high school would lose a significant amount of its enrollment.
A split and a subsequent decrease in enrollment would result in a significant decrease in a variety of AP and specialized classes.
Currently, Kalinga High School is able to offer eight AP classes and approximately 25 specialized or career technical education classes that include computer programming, welding, and AP calculus.
As a practical matter, the projected enrollment of the Kalinga High School in Huron would be approximately 436 students or 37% of the school's current population.
Most of the teachers at the current high school would have single subject credential.
This significant decrease in student population would act to prohibit the new high school in Huron from hiring the same number of certificated staff or a greater population filling the high school permits.
Therefore, the reduction in certificated staff would necessitate in reduction of type of classes offered to post high school in Huron.
Those who remain at Clinga High School also suffer as a result of proposed due to the decreased enrollment and therefore decreased class offerings.
The district estimates that the staff would need to be reduced by 22 certificated staff members and seven classified.
Is that time?
Yeah, that's time.
Thank you.
I'd be happy to answer any questions.
We can call them back if we need to, but I need to close the public hearing and
Do we want to go directly to public comment?
Usually we do that and then have questions.
Okay, call the roll.
Would the following people please line up?
Delora Silva, Ben Silva, Paul McLean Legowski, Ray Leon, Bonnie Garcia, William D. Ross, Veronica Aguirre, William Saladin,
Virginia Carneiro, Jenny Robledo, Maria Avena, Frank Avena, Marie Mejia, Jack Castro, Liz Guillen, Roberto Pimentel, Jorge Solario.
You can speak in just one moment.
Let me finish the list, please.
Bernardo Reyes and Rogelio Ramirez.
Thank you.
My name is Laura Silva.
Oh, right here?
I'm sorry.
My name is Laura Silva.
I am the chief petitioner.
I was a teacher for 31 years and retired.
I also served as a trustee of Kalinga-Huron Unified School District.
I attest to the unequal treatment in education between schools in Kalinga and Huron.
I ask that the State Board of Education approve the petition and send it to the voters of Huron.
Think about your own children.
You want the best for yours just like the people of Huron do.
Our students deserve to get an education and they're not being educated.
And we need your help.
Instead of having all these children, our students that drop out of school and end up, you know, doing hard labor,
or committing crimes or selling drugs.
We want to change this.
I have lived in Huron since 1948, and I have seen a lot of suffering.
And I'm telling you, the parents work very hard because they want their children just like you want the best for your children.
They want for them to get an education and not be on the heat, especially right now in the summertime.
Time is up.
Thank you.
suffering, you know, so much and not earning very much money.
And they want their children to be educated.
They go through a lot of hardship, the children and the families too.
Thank you.
It's one minute for the public commenters.
First of all, Benjamin Silva and
We've been working on this since 2005.
And the county, the school districts, they always come up with different numbers.
A demographer was hired.
They gave a number of 1,751.
Then from that point, they've tried to consistently lower that number because they want to make it
not financially viable.
In terms of bonding, we gave them two scenarios.
First scenario was the Harmony Magnet.
The second scenario was Vasquez High School of Act and Unified.
And both came in within $22 to $23 million.
So we don't know where they're getting their info from.
So we know we're viable.
In terms of segregation, they're traveling
I mean, 40 miles in one direction.
That's isolation.
That's a part of the law, distance between educational facilities.
Thank you.
Members of the Board and Chief Executive Officer Torlakson.
Thanks for the opportunity.
Paul McLean-Legowski.
I'm Chief Innovation Officer for Fresno County Economic Opportunities Commission and you may wonder what are we doing here?
We're an anti-poverty organization and have successfully worked and empowered
The residents in Fresno County that most need that have been doing that for 52 years now.
Huron is part of the county and we have invested greatly in Huron for obvious reasons.
The poverty rate, unemployment rate, unacceptably high in the 40 to 50 percent range.
We have Head Start programs there, employment programs, LIHEAP.
food distributions that take place regularly.
And today, we paid for a couple of vans to bring the residents of Huron here to this hearing.
Now, why would we do something like that?
Simply because this is important to us, important to that community.
And I want to underscore, we're not talking about numbers here exclusively.
We're not talking about dollars.
We're talking about students.
We're talking about people.
Thank you very much for your consideration.
Buenos dias.
Good morning.
My name is Ray Leon, mayor, city of Huron.
And I'll be really quick.
For the decades that we've been part of this district, you know, Huron is one of the poorest cities in the state of California.
And we know that education is the greatest equalizer when it comes to economic advancement.
We've been suffering under a district that's treated our children and our families not positively.
Desperate treatment.
You know, our monolingual Spanish-speaking families.
And we have a very diverse community.
We have over nine languages spoken in Huron.
alone.
Very diverse community.
It is most evident in regards to the disparate treatment.
It's most evident in the inequity and access to quality education, as the data depicts with the dropout rates, like the graduation rates, and also the A to the G completion.
Coalinga High School is in one of the worst of the, one of the worst high schools in the county, which only further aggravates the
the deficiencies.
Let me share a scenario.
Mendota, it's a city, farm worker city in Fresno County as well, shares our story.
They became their own district.
We are as big as they were then.
And now one of the, Ismael Herrera, you guys should have the letter of support as I conclude my comments, a letter of support from, he's a board member of Fresno County Office of Education.
And he shares that this is important to them as well because it's the same scenario.
And they've been able to grow economically and the students excel academically.
Thank you very much.
I hope you guys support us.
Thank you.
My name is Virginia V. Carnero.
a retired teacher for Kalinga Huron Unified School District.
At the present time, a substitute teacher for the area.
I'm here to represent the former Oil King District, of which I still reside, being an alumnus of Oil King School.
I can speak for the 131 students in the unincorporated area.
These students should be counted with the new Huron Unified District.
When the school was closed, many students were transferred to Huron School.
I would appreciate
a yes vote from the State Board of Education to approve the petition.
Thank you.
My name is Veronica Aguirre.
I'm a parent of two children that go to Huron Elementary.
I also reside in Huron.
I would like to ask for your support that you will consider our petition and allow the citizens of Huron to
have their own school district.
I don't believe that the as a citizen of Huron, we are not fairly represented within the district in regards to school board meetings and discussions.
I mean, and things that they do, especially like fiscally.
I did contact the school district one day or the school board or office to ask if they would consider having a meeting.
I saw a letter at the post office that said they were going to have a open meeting in regards to the budget.
I contacted the office to ask if they could possibly do it in Huron as well as Kalinga and they said that they do their meeting in Huron, I mean in Kalinga and in Huron they'll do decision making.
I don't believe that that's very fair and I don't believe that we are supported.
Thank you.
Okay, my name is Jenny.
I'm a Kalinga parent and I support Huron Unified School District.
There has been racism, racial segregation and favoritism in Kalinga Huron Unified School since our family started going to school in 1992.
There's something about feeling accepted that builds confidence in a student.
It sounds to me that money is the real reason why Huron Unified School District is being opposed.
The money is the root of all evil.
And we have to understand that at the end of the day, everybody in this room, including community members, teachers, board members, and all of you guys, we are all here to ensure the success of every Californian student equally across the board.
Thank you for your time.
I'm Maria Avina.
I'm here talking about taxation.
We were talking about the bonds and stuff.
It doesn't matter if Huron votes no on any of the bonds.
We just passed two, two years ago, and this last one.
Huron, even if we all vote no, they're going to pass the bonds.
It doesn't matter.
Coalinga, we're combined in the voting together.
And so what they do is, of course, if it passes in Coalinga, it doesn't matter what Huron has to say or doesn't have to say.
If you look at my property taxes, everything goes out of Huron and very little comes back in.
We even pay for West Hills College, for Lemoore and Kalinga.
We have no classes in Huron for West Hills.
We have very, we have nothing.
So if we vote, it doesn't matter if we vote no for a bond.
that we know we're going to get very little money of, because it doesn't matter.
We're still going to lose.
We're going to lose because we're not in the same amount of people.
And then we have five board members.
We have two from... Time.
Two from, you know, Huron and three from Kalinga.
It doesn't matter.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Frank Cabrera, longtime Huron resident.
I just want to read a little bit.
The Colina trustees are recalling each other.
The superintendent was just fired.
The chief business officer was relieved of his duties.
The district is scoring at the bottom of 5% of the state academically for over 20 years.
The district is in total chaos.
What would you want to keep it going?
I ask that the Board of Education approve the petition and send it to the voters of Huron.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Jack Castro, City of Huron.
The status quo is not consistent.
Therefore, we can't do this without our own separate Huron Unified School District making our own decision about our children's education.
We don't want the status quo anymore.
It is like old technology and it isn't working.
It isn't good enough.
Local ownership, innovative education, educational programs, increased graduation rates, attracting new businesses, expanding economic development.
decreased levels of poverty and increased social benefit currently in situation where we are essentially abdicating to a partisan board which may also have a conflict of interest.
The existing barriers to economic and social success are even stronger.
Please don't strengthen the barriers.
Instead, put ownership of this most important decision where it belongs in our community by approving our proposal for separate Huron-Uniford
Unified School District help us give our children the best and most innovative education possible and all of the positive social and economic benefits that follows.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Roberto Pimentel.
I teach at Huron Middle School, one of the feeder schools to the high school.
I'm a lifelong resident of Huron, and I'm on the city council.
I want to leave you with two words since I only have two minutes.
Institutional oppression.
That's what's going on at Calinga High School.
They very rarely talk to our middle school.
to collaborate for what's going on.
They very rarely invite our students over there for a tour of the school that they're going to attend.
So the main words I want to leave you with is institutional oppression.
Everything that you see from their high school dropout rates, it's maneuvered.
They communicate very, very little with the parents before they send the kids to continuation schools.
When that happens,
All of a sudden, they clean their hands and those kids didn't drop out from our school.
Yes, they did.
You sent them there.
So just keep that in mind, please.
And I am an employee of the district and I've seen it happen.
Our school just got recognized this year as a national schools to watch.
Nobody got sent from the district, not a superintendent, not the assistant superintendent, not a board member, because it was Huron Middle School that made it, not Calinga.
Thank you.
My name is Jorge Solorio.
I'm a third grade teacher at Huron Elementary and a council member in Huron.
We work really hard to motivate our Huron kids to dream high, to go for their goals, only to have them get to Coalinga and have those dreams squashed.
That is really unfair to our kids.
Recently, one of the Coalinga school board members referred to Huron as those people.
how that just goes to highlight what Conninger really thinks about Huron.
When they refer to us as those people, really sets the tone to what they really feel.
So I think in order for us to get an equal and fair opportunity, we do need our own district.
So thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Rogelio Ramirez.
I'm a former alumni for Coalinga High School, class of 2015.
I'm currently a civil engineer, or starting to be a civil engineer at UC Davis.
I just want to hear and represent that I am a true example of what's going on.
Going through the process of the four years, I was told by a counselor, are you sure you can make it to a UC?
You should see how much that devastated me.
Within the AP classes, of course, they say, we have all these AP classes.
But the ratio of Huron to Coalinga students is 4 to 1.
Come on, seriously?
35 Calinga students and only four from Huron?
What's that all about?
It doesn't make any sense.
Really, all my friends, everyone who I knew, they either dropped out of community college, didn't even go for a four-year, or even transferred out of community college.
I'm just putting this out there.
It's not fair.
Institutional privilege is present within the district.
Thank you, and enjoy the rest of your day.
Good morning.
I'm Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
I wanted to share that in 2006 and 2007, we supported an organized group of parents, mostly moms, but other community stakeholders, in asserting their rights under the Williams Settlement around facilities, and specifically water.
They worked for over a year and it took uniform complaints and embarrassing through the media to get some changes.
Bathrooms cleaned and bottled water.
Fast forward to today, seeing this and hearing this, reading the papers, it doesn't seem like very much has changed.
We think there are a lot of exceptional circumstances.
not just in the criteria that you have to consider, but other educational provision or lack thereof.
And we support the community and I urge you to take your decision seriously and consider all these circumstances.
Thank you.
Good morning, members.
My name is Genesis Tang, and I'm here on behalf of Assemblymember Arambula, who represents the city of Huron.
I would like to read a portion of the letter that was sent on behalf of the California Latino Legislative Caucus.
Dear board members, on behalf of the California Latino Legislative Caucus, we ask that as you review the request to create the Huron Unified School District, that you consider the implications for the students who live in Huron.
Students who live in Huron must spend a significant portion of their day on a bus commuting to and from high school in the city of Coalinga.
According to a long-term study by the Harvard University, the single strongest factor in determining someone's economic life chances is not the local crime rate or their education, but how long it takes to get to school or work.
Students' long daily commutes to Coalinga High School create undue challenges for students.
The Coalinga-Huron Unified School District currently has a 43% dropout rate, and the time and distance the students commute must be a contributing factor.
We appreciate the State Board of Education's dedication, efforts, and contributions to the academic development of our youth and ask that you consider the immediate and long-term positive impacts on the community of Huron as it pursues the feasibility of establishing the Huron Unified School District.
Thank you for your time.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Bernardo Reyes.
I also went through the Kalinga-Huron Unified School District journey as a student.
And I'm here to share a little bit as to why I feel that Huron needs its own district.
Let's just look at the high school graduation rates and also the A through G completion rates, which is what our students' future is.
If they're not completing A through G,
their doors are pretty much closed.
So please consider that when we're talking about creating a new district for our community.
Also, I just also wanted to reflect upon the rebuttal that we heard this morning as to why
Huron shouldn't have a school district and never did I hear a reason, a positive reason of why Huron students should keep going to Coalinga.
Not one did I hear that today.
And clearly we can see that there is no representation of the Huron community at Coalinga-Huron Unified School District at this point.
That's the reason why Huron needs its own district.
Thank you.
Good morning, Mr. Chairman, members of the board.
My name is Bill Ross.
I'm an attorney with law offices in Palo Alto.
I don't have a horse in this race.
I know the petitioners through their interaction with the special district that I represent in Fresno.
My area of practice predominantly is focused on LAFCO proceedings, the functional equivalent for what you're doing now for other units of local government.
I think you should exercise your discretion and send it back.
I think there are procedural due process problems with the county hearing.
Among them, there's no record.
You can't even access minutes on the website.
There's no recounting of extra party communications.
Many of the individuals on the committee appeared to be reading from script when they analyzed issues that came before it.
I would respectfully suggest that there are two areas with the staff presented to you that are incorrect.
The first is with respect to the bond proceeds being allocated, causing an increase in property taxes in Coalinga.
Four decades of law under Article Proposition 13 would indicate that's incorrect.
Also, there's no analysis of the issue for facilities of joint financing through joint power authority agreements.
I suggest there is an example of that in American Canyon, California.
where that took place between that city and the Napa Valley Unified School District.
I implore you to exercise your discretion.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Alejandra Lopez.
I grew up in Huron.
I graduated from Calinga High School in 2012, and I just graduated from UC Berkeley this May.
But we are very few because we need our high school.
Not very, very few of us graduate from high school and very few of us make it to four years.
In my eighth grade geometry class in Huron Middle School, we were 27 students that could have made it to AP Calculus my junior year.
My junior year, I was the only one that made it to AP Calculus.
The school did not support us.
When I told my counselor that I got admitted to UC Berkeley, they told me I should consider community college instead.
That's the discouragement our students are receiving, even the quote-unquote high-performing students.
Thank you for your time.
Okay, that concludes the public comment.
And now we're ready for questions from board members.
Ortiz-Lacombe.
Bruce, yeah, maybe you want to start first again, if you want to.
So I am the liaison for this district reorganization set of issues that come up from time to time.
I do want to commend Larry and his staff for just a tremendously thorough job that you do on each of these.
I'm always so impressed.
This one is
even more complicated, perhaps, than some of the other ones that we've looked at in recent years in that the issues surrounding each of the nine thresholds are significant and complex.
And first of all, I just want to commend the staff and Larry in particular for making sure that they've looked under every stone as they go through this process.
With that said, I'll let the rest of the board go ahead and ask questions and then be happy to come back in a minute.
Okay, Ortiz-Lacon was first, yeah.
Yeah, so one of the reasons that I stated earlier that I do think we need to have a financially solvent model for this is because I do believe that every student deserves a quality education.
And that does require money, whether we want to admit, you know, to put the students first.
We want to put the students first, but we want to align resources to provide that model.
But in hearing some of the testimonies, you know, it saddens me.
I feel like this meeting could be taking place in the 1960s, given the concerns that we're still hearing.
The face of inequality is within our audience right now.
And when people choose and want to resegregate,
That tells you that this model of integration is only benefiting those with certain privileges and not all of the students.
So that model is clearly not working.
People are letting you know, this is the biggest signal that I've heard, that what you think is welcoming, what you think is integration, is obviously not, and it needs to be reconsidered.
Regardless of what decision takes place today, I think that there is definitely a call of urgency to change practices that are making some students
feel othered in the campus that's supposed to welcome them and educate them properly.
And that is definitely a concern that I have.
I also feel that the governance system is obviously not set up, not that we have anything to do with that, but clearly when you have a three to two vote, it's not properly set up to represent all.
But I want to go back to the $43.59 discrepancy that was quoted and cited here.
Can you tell us a little bit more about how that number has changed from 43%, which some feel that that was the appropriate number, to now 59% of the bond debt?
Sure.
The 43%
Let me back up for a moment.
The education code requires that when we do this, do our analysis, that we work the information that we use to analyze, it has to come to the county superintendent and the affected school district.
So that's the source for all our information.
The 43% came up in the very early consideration of the proposal at the local school district.
They, I believe, Koalinga-Huron said that that was the case.
At that time, you know, petitioners opposed that number, said it was incorrect.
Later on in the process, Koalinga-Huron came back with a higher number.
There was no percentage assigned to it, but, you know,
comparing the number that, that the total assessed valuation that Kuala Lunga Huron put forward at the end of the local hearings and what we received to the county superintendent, that looks like it's about 59%.
And again, the petitioners did not support that number.
As you heard now, they want to go back to the original number they didn't support.
So, that said,
To me, you know, I've been doing this for 30 years dealing with reorganization issues.
And this is really the first time and this is kind of a general comment.
This is really the first time that I've experienced petitioners coming before the county committee or the state board trying to convince you that they have the funding capability to build a school and then asking you to consider that they should have less money to do that.
because when you talk about 59% of the assessed valuation, that's something that a district pulling away, they would want to jack up that number because that's what's going to help them build that school.
The assessed valuation and then the bonding capacity that comes from that, the two and a half percent of the assessed valuation.
If you run the numbers, under 59, and this is just for an example, under 59%,
Their bonding cap is, as we indicated, is about $31.5 million.
And if we use that percentage also to account for their liability for existing bond and indebtedness, that's about $13.5 million.
And you heard the figure of $18 million being available to build the high school.
And that's the difference between 31.5 and 13.5.
But if we use the 43%,
then their bonding cap is $23 million.
The percent of bonded indebtedness that they're obligated to drops about $4.5 million to about $9 million.
$23 million minus $9 million is now $14 million.
So if we go to that 43%, they actually have less money, $4 million less, available to finance school construction in the new district.
If you move this forward, and if they want to go back to 43%, I mean, that's something, if they're formed, they could probably work that out with Coalinga.
I'm sure Coalinga, the remaining Coalinga district would be very happy to reduce the amount of assessed valuation that they're losing.
But, you know, it doesn't really, in terms of the numbers and the amount of money they have, the more assessed valuation you bring into the district,
the more money you're going to have to build a high school.
So I'm just, it's kind of confuses me why they're arguing that they should have less money.
But I don't know if that answers your question.
But the numbers come from the, come through the county office, county superintendent, primarily probably from the school district or the county assessor.
We don't ask, we didn't have a source for the data.
But, you know, my bigger confusion is why there,
why they're arguing they should have less money.
Board member Strauss.
So I want to thank all the community that came forward to share their voices and to share and the graduates who shared their actual experiences in the school.
And as a former school principal, you spoke to my heart about the guidance or lack of guidance and the issues that affected your potential following high school graduation.
And I think
I know I speak for many board members who we really want students to have opportunities through high school and beyond.
And so the educational opportunities, I think, are important to offer both Coalinga and Huron students.
So that being said, I feel like we're in a
and a dilemma between understanding that the community of Huron wants to be respected, wants their own schools, wants to be proud, wants their students to give the best opportunity and yet we've got a financial dilemma.
So I've watched this and I've worked in communities that have had that and so I understand and I wonder if there's a way and so I'm not sure elementary, middle, in order to limit the number of transitions between schools.
Is that something that they could look at with the existing facilities to maybe create a K-8 or a K-6 and a 7-12?
Is that something that would then require less facility money to build a brand new facility and then address this dilemma of not having enough money to actually build the high school?
I just wonder if that's a possibility.
Certainly, it's a possibility.
There are many options that could be, you know, the problem we have here
is that those, you know, what the Huron school district is going to do in regard to facilities will be determined by the governing board.
And we don't have a governing board of that district at this point.
There's just a lot of, you know, what we want.
I mean, you know, the petitioners are saying they want a
a high school.
And that's what our analysis is based on, the high school.
And a lot of our, especially the educational program condition, was that this high school would provide a similar program as an existing high school.
But there are a lot of options out there.
They would probably need some space, but if they would bring portables in or
offer a smaller academy thing, academy style high school with fewer facilities that are going to cost more, cost less.
But, you know, our analysis was based on providing an equivalent program, equivalent educational program, and our numbers reflect that.
But there are a lot of options out there, yes, certainly.
But there's nobody, there's nobody elected as the new governing board that's going to tell us what the new district would actually do.
Well, and then go ahead.
And that's my only follow up.
I'm just in kind of looking up the district and finding background beyond what we were submitted.
They currently, according to the newspaper, put their current superintendent on leave last month.
So there's an interim superintendent.
So I just wonder if we understand what's going on with governance or whether that impacts at all what's happening with this petition.
I don't know if that, what the impacts are.
A lot of their, you know, we have been dealing with this issue for a year and a half in terms of collecting the data and doing our analysis.
And I understand there have been some changes in the district.
You know, I wasn't aware of the superintendent issue, but I know they're looking for a new CBO at the district.
So, I don't know if we have a representative from the County Office of Education here.
They might be able to provide a little more insight.
I can't help you.
I'm sorry.
I can't help you with that.
Okay.
I just wanted to clarify here for a minute.
Ladies and gentlemen, thank you very much.
My name is Chris Lozano.
I'm with the office of the... Excuse me.
I'm with the Fresno County Superintendent of Schools Office representing the Fresno Commissioning Committee on School District Organization.
I was in the overflow room, so I apologize for being a little bit out of breath.
The question?
So apparently the district has a, they released their superintendent on leave a month ago and they're also looking for a CBO.
So it's not a big district.
It's 4,400 kids and they're missing two really key leaders of the current district.
So I just wondered if there was clearly some instability at the senior management level and just wonder if there's just a combination, if there's any information you could share with us that would help us.
It seems like there's just a lot of instability going on in this district right now.
Certainly, the district faces challenges.
I can report that it is the only district in Fresno County that is in a qualified status right now.
In a qualified fiscal status?
Correct.
FCMAT, the fiscal crisis and management team has been tasked to go out there and they're working with them.
The challenges exist, however, I can tell you that.
The district did submit a fiscal recovery plan.
Candidly, that seems to be predicated primarily on negotiated items with their collective bargaining unit that have yet to actually be negotiated.
So, there appears at this point to be essentially a
a structural fiscal deficit of about 1.5 to 1.8 million dollars.
That is correct.
Yes, ma'am.
It is not clear.
Currently, they're drawing down on reserves to meet their bills.
It is not clear, however, what the long-term solution is going to be.
But as I said, the county superintendent and FCMAT are working with the personnel who are out there.
They are indeed looking for a new superintendent and a new CBO.
So it is a difficult situation.
I don't think anybody is saying that it isn't.
It's just the position of the county committee that this is not the solution to that problem.
Yeah, I just wanted to clarify before we have another question.
We have to act on the, this is like a charter petition.
No, in the sense that we have to act on what is in the petition rather than speculate about what might be if we had build off in a middle school and so on, or can we just freeform it?
Yeah, this is Mr. Shirey.
Well, it depends on what you're speculating on.
You cannot make decisions that a new governing board is going to have to make.
So you cannot put in the plans and recommendations that they're going to have to build X facility or do whatever to an existing middle school.
That's nothing that you cannot commit a governing board to take those actions.
The flexibility you have is in terms of how you divide assets
of the existing schooling, the school district, how bond and indebtedness gets divided, issues related to, and that's primarily the area that you have flexibility in terms of what you can put in the plans and recommendations of the proposal.
Excuse me?
Go ahead.
Right.
You know, once you approve it, you're going to have to determine what goes in the plans and recommendations that the voters can read and understand when they vote.
And in that will be size of governing board, how bonds will be divided, how assets and obligations will be divided just to give the voters some information about what the reorganization would accomplish.
So then it goes back to the voter.
So if we were to
give it, move it to the next step.
It's still not approved at this point.
No, it has to go back to the county because it is a project under the California Environmental Quality Act.
So, you as a state board, you're the lead agency for that.
you know, someone at the local level will have to take fiscal responsibility for completing the CEQA analysis under your oversight.
So when they finish that process, they will then bring that back.
We will then, the department will then present to you the findings of CEQA and then this action item again with any updated information we have for your final action to determine whether to disapprove.
Excuse me.
That's going to take some time, right?
I'm not sure, you know, it can take, you know, the last environmental impact report that if that's what it goes to.
Some of you may remember Wiseburn School District, you know, we had that here 10 years.
Because one of the things is that about CEQA is it's so easy to litigate.
It's, you know, things can just get expensive and they can and things start,
You know, we've tried many, many times to get reorganizations out from under the CEQA umbrella, but it doesn't work.
Superintendent.
Just a couple of observations.
I'm glad Board Member Strauss brought up that there are other alternatives.
And regardless of how you all decide today on this petition, seems
there's something seriously amiss in the district, in the community, and it needs a facilitation, intervention.
I'm going to talk to Carl Cohn and Sue Burr.
I'm on the collaborative.
This is an issue that even whichever way you went on the decision,
If you went forward with a separate district, it's a five-year process.
In the meantime, kids are compromised, communication seems very dysfunctional.
So I'm letting you know that one way or the other, whatever you're doing, I think we need to go back to the community and I'll try to find some resources with Carl Cohen and the collaborative.
This is just a kind of a situation actually.
The collaborative is designed to
be available to help with, so just wanted to give you that information.
Board Member Ruckers next.
So I want to begin also by thanking the department staff.
I've been on the board now for a number of years and I'm always impressed not only by the expertise that the staff has in presenting these very technical issues to the board and developing very clear and concise reports.
I also want to thank the parents and the community members
who came to speak today.
I know that I felt your frustration in speaking for a minute, but, you know, if you only have a minute, I want you to know everything that you had to say really and truly was heard.
When people outside of the state of California think about this state, there are five cities that immediately come to their mind.
And Coalinga, Huron is not one of them.
But I will say as a child of the military, for me, thinking about small towns and hometowns for a person who grew up moving every single year, Coalinga and Huron are definitely the cities in my mind that came to my mind as a picture of what California really is.
And it's not because they represent small towns, but they represent the kind of small towns that I came from in Mississippi.
These small towns have deep roots, they have big family structures, and they have norms and patterns as a community in which they operate.
But those deep roots also include a lot of long-standing dysfunction and privilege that people have a hard time of letting go of.
And so I understand that and I heard that very clearly.
One of the things, one of the reasons why yesterday I was hanging on to so hard about the issue of accountability and what our new accountability system is supposed to do and my dissatisfaction with what was written in the state plan and my concerns about what the staff presented to us about the draft intervention plan is that nothing we approved yesterday is going to address
or hold accountable the school board in Kuala Lumpur, Iran to stop what they have been doing for all of these years.
And so, that is my concern.
So, let's take a look at the criteria.
The nine criteria that the staff went through cover a lot of issues.
And the most serious and compelling issues are about the fiscal concerns.
Added to the fact that this district has a qualified status, it only magnifies the concerns about what criteria the new district could not possibly meet.
In my over and this, Larry, I'm going to tell you right now, the next sentence I'm going to state is incorrect, but I'm saying it to make a point.
If the district is already in a qualified financial status, splitting the district into two districts only doubles the financial problem.
And I do know that that's an inaccurate statement, but in my mind, in my way of understanding what that status is actually going to do, it's not going to solve the qualified financial status.
It's actually going to create problems for both new districts.
I have that concern.
But what I have not heard and one of the things that was very clear, one of the issues that was very clearly discussed by the community members who came.
is the criteria and the issues that the law does not allow me to consider.
The fact that there were very poor practices in leadership in providing equity, in the equitable distribution of power and recognition and school support for those students.
Those are not things that the criteria allows me to consider.
But those are the things, when you look at me, that are closest and dearest to my heart, because I stand on the shoulders of my cousins and my family members who had to deal with those same things.
And to the young man who's going to UC Davis, go Aggies.
I'm a Davis alumni, so congratulations.
But the problem is, that's not the criteria I'm allowed to consider.
When I took my oath of office to sit in this chair, I had to uphold the laws of this state.
And the criteria that I'm supposed to consider in making the decision about this application does not allow me to consider the fact that you have people in elected office
who are not upholding their responsibility to the people in that community.
But I'm not allowed to consider that and they have to rely on my responsibility and obligation as a public official not to consider their misbehavior and their misdeeds.
So the question about what alternatives does the board have doesn't rest on what we can approve today.
Because anything that's approved or disapproved, if we approve the petition to allow the two districts to split,
A child who is in kindergarten today will graduate from high school before a new high school will open.
So what is going to happen in the interim, in the period of time where the lawsuits and the CEQA challenges and all of the reviews that have to be done to create this new district and establish this new governance is going on, what corrections can happen to address the dysfunction in governance that's very clearly occurring in this district?
What did we approve yesterday in our state plan concerning ESSA that will get the district's attention?
In what way does the accountability system and all the information the dashboard is supposed to say to help districts pay attention to what they should be correcting?
How is that going to approve or improve teaching and learning and the quality of the educational experience for those students in the interim?
These are things I am not allowed to consider.
So what does disapproving this petition mean?
Obviously, for the people who are in charge, for the board members who have the three to two majority, it simply means they've won.
Because I heard nothing from the district when they made their presentation to recognize and show an understanding of the fact that there is a problem.
And what I'm more concerned about if I follow the requirements of the law,
We will change nothing and the governing structure and the governing behavior of the current school board will not change.
And I can say that with an assurance because I heard nothing from the people who made a presentation representing the district to say that they understand the purpose and the reasons behind this petition have more to do with poor management and poor behavior on district leadership than the actual issues and the desire to create a community identity.
by creating a new district.
And this district has chosen to ignore all of those things.
So I have a great concern.
I'm very concerned about what the dysfunction in this community that is longstanding and that it cannot be addressed by either decision from this board in deciding this petition.
And I remain concerned that no matter what we decide, those concerns will remain longstanding and in place.
So I'd like some advice on that.
Yeah.
Trish Williams.
So this is a, this is quite the dilemma here.
And to hear that the district is qualified and dipping into reserves, losing their CBO, don't have a superintendent is disturbing about the district.
and the governance and the management.
I am compelled and moved by the Huron parents and former students whose messages were very consistent in terms of how left out they felt, how misunderstood or deliberately not understood.
I can picture in my eyes, in my mind, going on an hour bus ride every day and getting to get to the high school, missing out on before and after school activities, and getting behind.
If there's research that correlates long distance travel, which makes sense to me, getting to school, making it difficult with dropout, with chronic absence, then I can see that group of kids being funneled over to the continuation schools.
not being put in the A through G or AP classes.
I can see how that could just go on and on.
But what also was, and I'm not going to cut, I don't have a solution for what exactly approve or don't approve.
But this interim, this intermediate kind of solution that member Strauss was talking about in terms of the, does it have to be a brand new high school?
Could it be a middle high school?
I mean, I even thought, could it be a charter school?
There's all kinds of ways maybe for Huron to not, that would solve a not have to travel that long distance problem.
Doesn't solve all the problems, but that would solve that problem.
But it feels to me that if Koalinga
is in this kind of fiscal shape, the last thing they want to have happen is for Huron to take their students to their own school district.
That is not going to help Coalinga's fiscal condition.
It's going to make it worse if these students go into their own district.
So if I were in charge of Coalinga,
and that were a situation and I had this, had been in this meeting and heard what was being said and I needed those students, then I would recognize that I need their parents and their family and that community support and that they have some very legitimate concerns and problems that I had better start addressing.
if I want them to work with me to make sure that this whole district is fiscally sound again, can be fiscally sound again.
I would give a lot to make sure they wanted to be in that district and find ways to work with, I heard superintendent,
Torlakson say that he can have some people facilitate and work with the whole community to see if there can't be something in between the breakup of the district, but no longer going on with the ignoring of the needs of Huron and its families and its students.
That's what I would hope would happen regardless of the vote on the breakup or not breakup.
Board Member Sun.
What would have been the ADA number for this new district?
1,500, something like that?
It was about 1,570, I think.
I know there was some concern expressed by the petitioners.
But, you know, that was kind of an apple to oranges comparison.
So under 2000.
ADA, the numbers they threw out, the district number of 1620 is an enrollment figure, which is actually would be lower if it... Right, for ADA.
Yeah.
The other two numbers were based on census data.
Certainly the Census Bureau numbers were census data.
And I'm assuming that the demographer who they hired to redraw trustee areas, they typically use census data.
I haven't worked directly with census data in a while, but I don't recall them being able to identify people in high school.
Yeah, I got the ballpark part of this.
Yeah.
So, first of all, to the folks who brought this to us, the Huron folks, I hear you and I hear the frustration in your voices and I hear that the desperation in your voices in wanting to create your own district.
And I would say to you, as I would say to a charter petitioner that
Yeah, it's very difficult, but you have to have a vision for where you're going, not just running away or trying to get away.
You've got to have a plan moving forward.
And certainly with that number, I operated 1,800 student charter school.
And I can tell you, it is hard.
It is difficult financially to manage.
all of that and to want to develop a comprehensive high school with all of the facilities and with the challenges that's in your community, it is a very difficult thing.
It might sound like, hey, we want to start our own district, but it is a very difficult thing to manage.
And I would rather see with some inspired leadership somewhere and some assistance that you find some other types of solution within your community.
And I know that's difficult.
Just to board member Rucker's point, I could not help as well to look at the dashboard for this district and use it as a test for our system, our accountability system.
And and as we're kind of working these things out, I think we could.
These are these are the tests that we can look at to see if the system works.
But we do currently have a system.
And I wonder where the county office has been in looking at the district's LCAP and assessing what the what the community input has been on it.
And just looking at the draft LCAP that's been posted on the district's website, it is incomplete.
right now.
I don't see a completed one.
And that is where our system, we have some oversight right now with the County Office of Education.
And I'm wondering where that process is.
So while not necessarily looking at, oh, we now need to figure out at the state level, it doesn't, it's not supposed to all happen to that state level.
There should have been some local regional oversight before it got to this point.
So yeah, at some point we need to summarize a decision we have to make.
And we're getting into a lot of school improvement here.
And we'd like, I'd like to get us back to what we're, what's on the agenda.
Ortiz-Lacon and Patricia Rucker again.
And I do have, I do need clarification on what we're actually voting on.
But, you know, I think that it's, we have to get into these conversations because yesterday's conversation was so abstract and today is so real and how it all works together.
I, the good news is that you're now on the radar.
I have never, I'm Southern California, I have never, I apologize, heard of your district or Huron.
And now that I do, te quiero mucho, Huron.
Los quiero y los deseo lo mejor.
And I'm so glad that Superintendent Torlakson has, wants to pursue this.
And I think that everyone has made very valid points in terms of where has the oversight been.
And that's a grave concern.
In terms of the actual options, I'm still a little lost because I understand that it goes back to the local if we go with the CEQA compliance.
But then I heard something about the voters.
So let's go back to the disapprove.
So if we disapprove, does that kill?
They cannot start all over again.
That's the end of it.
Or they would have to start all over again with their petition.
And then two, it goes back to the local, it undergoes CEQA, and then it comes back to us so that it could go on a ballot.
No, it comes back to you for another session like we have right now.
You're going to have to, it goes back to CEQA, I mean it goes back to the local levels for CEQA compliance.
And then it's going to come back to you as two action items.
You're going to have to accept the CEQA findings.
initially.
And once you accept those, you move to pretty much an identical situation we have right now.
We're going to update our analysis.
Things may change.
I don't know how long it's going to be.
It could be five years down the road before.
It might be a whole new board here.
But we're going to have to prepare.
We're going to, you know, I took, you know, going back to Weisbord, I brought four, I brought four, four agenda items to you over ten years.
So you don't have to bring another agenda item back on the issue.
And if you decide at that point in time to approve it, it then directs the county superintendent to call an election in the area.
If it's approved that election, then the district could go into effect the July 1st of the subsequent year.
OK, board member Rucker.
So I want to thank board member Ting for bringing up the point that I was making.
I did because I did not want to go there and get into the conversation about school improvement.
But what is happening here is happening because we have institutions and artifacts and a framework in place for intervention and support and for redirecting schools when they get into this type of problem and redirecting the work of LEAs.
It didn't work.
And so if you ask the question where the county office was, sitting in the county office.
So I'm trying to be very careful and not sound hypercritical about what happened, but the lack of dysfunction and poor management and work that people who got paid a lot of money to do this should have been going on didn't just stop at the district office in Coalinga, Huron.
But the problem is, and the question before us, is this the way to solve that problem?
is voting to approve the petition going to solve the governance problem.
And if that's the reason why this board would vote to do that, we're using factors to consider that vote other than what the law says we're supposed to consider.
But there are consequences and there are considerable consequences for voting not to approve the petition.
And so we have to consider that as well.
So there are consequences either way this vote goes.
And both of them are long-term and sustained consequences.
Anybody who thinks this vote that happens today
is going to immediately see something change tomorrow, regardless of whether the vote is yes to approve or no to disapprove, doesn't understand the long-term activities that will be in front of not only this board, but the county office, as well as the local school board that will still have to oversee this as the process goes forward.
So that's the other part that we're not allowed to consider either.
But that's a reality.
And that's the elephant in the room.
It's a large, unmanageable, hot mess.
And if we vote to approve this, it becomes our mess.
Well, somebody else's because I'm sure we won't all be on the board for the next 10 years.
I'd like to call on our liaison and as you then give your views, as you looked at this, whether you saw a viable financial plan for this proposed reorganization.
So over the years, I ran various charter schools and facilities.
There's always a real issue with charter schools.
And I went through the whole process of trying to figure out how to build a new school that would be a middle and high school in American Canyon, actually, was one possibility, and other places.
And they are very expensive.
They are very expensive.
They're very complicated.
And this state process is lengthy with the state architect and the environmental issues and on and on.
It's a huge undertaking.
And when I looked at, along with Larry, with the financial realities of this situation, it would be a huge undertaking.
And it's very likely that it would fail in a number of ways.
It's also very likely that it's going to be a severe hardship on
the remaining district, the Koalinga district.
But I think all my colleagues have expressed everything.
This was an easy lead assignment that you all expressed exactly what I was feeling and what I wanted to talk about in that we do care deeply about students.
We do care deeply about communities.
We do care deeply about community identities.
I do think there are other options and other ways of solving this issue.
I fully respect the superintendent's generous offer to look into this community's struggles and to try to help in every way possible.
I think there are other resources available such as the coalition.
I think that
Member Ting's comment about the county stepping up to the LCAP responsibility is a very important point.
I do think charter schools are also potentially an option.
There are lots of other things that maybe you've considered and thought about.
I do not believe that this is an appropriate
district reorganization that is in front of us for the reasons that the CDE has articulated.
And therefore, unfortunately, it's my sad duty, but my duty to make the recommendation to move the staff recommendation.
Your second?
No second?
I will second.
Any further board discussion?
Board Member Williams.
I do think the fact that there isn't a CBO and there isn't a superintendent currently at the district is actually an opening for change.
It's an opportunity to do something different.
the board will need to do something different.
They have this opportunity to pick people that will understand not only your fiscal situation, but understand what brought this community from Huron all the way here to us because they are so desperate for educational opportunities for their children.
So this is now an opportunity for you.
And if we can get the Collaborative for Education Excellence involved and get the county to oversee more closely how you are, what's in your LCAP and whether or not you're including the community of Huron and giving, going to them.
not asking them to take an hour bus to you, but going to them to give input into the LCAP, express what they need.
You have a really good opportunity here to serve them as well as better serve and better manage your organization.
And I hope, Superintendent Torlakson, that, you know, I will count on you to follow through to get the right people involved to make that happen.
And look forward to hearing an update.
Board Member Sandoval.
I just want to just express my appreciation to all of you just for presenting today and the thorough work that was done by the department.
The fact that 43% of your students leave school
have to travel two to three hours round trip every day.
There's no excuse.
There are solutions.
There are ways to support you in your development.
So I'm sorry that it took this long to get the attention of people to support you and your community.
And so now you have a lot more people watching.
And there's no excuse for the lack of educational resources and support that you've suffered through.
So you have the attention now at the state level and I hope at the county level in a much bigger way.
And my hope is that we can help transform the outcomes for you and your community.
And this was not an easy decision to make at all.
Okay.
We're not ready for a vote yet.
I'd like to move to a vote fairly soon.
Okay.
You ready for a vote?
Good.
Okay.
I think let's call a roll on this because we had trouble getting a second.
So let's start there with Holiday and go around.
Bruce Holiday.
Yes.
Nikki Sandoval.
Olivia Sison.
Trish Williams.
Ting Sung.
Mike Kirst?
Yes.
Elaine Strauss?
Felisa Ortiz-Lucon?
No.
And Patricia Rucker?
Okay, it passes.
Seven to two.
Okay, so that item is complete and I think the board needs a break, so we will come back at 20 of 12.
Okay, the board will reconvene.
We have six members.
I'm counting Ortiz-Lacombe.
We will proceed to item 19.
Petition for the establishment of a charter school under the oversight of the State Board of Education, Sweetwater Secondary School.
So we're ready now for the CDE presentation on this.
CDE presentation.
Okay, we're ready, Cindy, for you.
We've already called the roll and we have our quorum if you're ready.
Okay, good morning Board President Kirst, members of the Board, I'm Cindy Tan, Director of the Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
Item 19 is an appeal by Sweetwater Secondary School to establish a new charter school, which was denied by the Sweetwater Union High School District and the San Diego County Board of Education.
Pursuant to statute, petitioners for a charter school that have been denied at the local level may petition the State Board of Education for approval subject to certain conditions.
The CDE received the Sweetwater petition on March 3rd and staff have reviewed the petition documents and information submitted by the petitioner.
And based on our review, we are recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing and thereafter approve with technical amendments and three conditions.
The request to establish Sweetwater under the oversight of the State Board for a five-year term effective July 1, 2017 through June 30, 2022.
Our recommendation includes the following three conditions.
So condition one, Sweetwater may contract with Student Success Programs, Incorporated, Altus Institute, Incorporated, Altus Muras, Incorporated, Altus Laurel, Incorporated, or any other affiliated or related organizations.
for goods and or services if all such related entities agree to timely respond to all CDE inquiries into their operations including but not limited to management, fiscal, personnel, procurement, programmatic, advocacy, outreach, professional development, supervisory, facilities operations, facilities financing, and service agreements.
in accordance with Education Code Section 47604.3 and fully cooperate with any investigation into their operations conducted pursuant to Education Code Section 47604.4.
Condition 2, Student Success Programs Incorporated, Altus Institute Incorporated, Altus Meris Incorporated and Altus Laurel Incorporated and or any other affiliates agree to timely respond to all CD inquiries regarding negotiations, revisions and or amendments.
to master agreements between Sweetwater and any of the related entities, and to provide the CDE with a reasonable opportunity to review any new agreements entered into between Sweetwater and any affiliates.
And condition three, Sweetwater must adhere to the terms and conditions as noted in attachment one of the item, which is the California State Board of Education standard conditions on opening and operation.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools considered the Sweetwater petition at its June 7th meeting and unanimously voted to approve CDE's recommendation that the State Board approve the Sweetwater petition with the technical amendments and conditions proposed by the CDE.
Sweetwater is modeled after the Charter School of San Diego, which is a charter school authorized by the San Diego Unified School District and will provide an independent study homeschool setting with a focus on providing a personalized educational program for its pupils with special emphasis on expanding learning opportunities for pupils who are identified as academically low achieving.
Sweetwater proposes to serve 300 pupils in grade 7 through grade 12 in 2017-18, its first year of operation, expanding to 480 pupils in grade 7 through grade 12 by year 4, 2021.
Sweetwater proposes to operate three resource centers located within the boundaries of the Sweetwater Union High School District that currently operate under the Charter School San Diego, a charter school authorized by San Diego Unified School District.
So as you recall, and we didn't have
an item that I presented for you at this meeting, but the board approved a waiver policy in March and you have seen before you a couple of sets of waivers that have dealt with a recent court decision that came down.
We've referred to it as Anderson.
It was a decision, an appellate court decision that
clarified the law that states that charter schools that operate resource centers, non-classroom based charter schools, they have to comply with the boundary requirements as classroom based schools.
So the kind of the, to summarize, a charter school resource center must operate within the boundaries of its authorizing school district or an adjacent county subject to certain conditions.
So the Sweetwater petition was first submitted to Sweetwater Union High School District in October 2016.
And so while this was prior to the final Anderson court decision, I think there was some confusion as to maybe what was provided in the petition.
It was before the final decision and I don't know if it was, you know, foresight on their part or if they just had chose to seek separate authorization.
By doing so, this is one of the compliance measures of that court decision.
So charter schools that are operating non-compliant resource centers, they can either close them down, they can get a new charter in that district where they're operating and that's what this charter school chose to do.
They were denied so they're here before you today.
So this is one of the compliant
Yes.
Yep.
We already have two.
And so I'll go into that with the governance section.
So department staff have reviewed this.
We wrote a petition supporting documents and we find that it meets the standards and criteria.
Requirements provides a reasonably comprehensive description of the required elements with our technical amendments that we're recommending.
We also reviewed the Sweetwater multi-year fiscal plan, which we note kind of similar to the Grossmont petition that was brought before you at the last meeting.
There is an unsubstantiated resource included.
It was $500,000, a beginning cash balance with no assumptions or narrative.
On March 30th, the Board of Student Success Programs Incorporated, which is another organization that we had mentioned in our recommendation.
They approved a resolution to transfer funds from a resource center of theirs, a positive net balance of funds upon granting of a duly authorized charter petition.
And by doing so, Sweetwater received no less than a little over a million dollars.
However, since the transfer of funds we found per that resolution is contingent upon a number of things happening, we have excluded those monies from our budget assumptions.
By doing so, it brings their cash balance down to roughly $120,000 and the reserves just right below 5%.
So it's fairly close.
Therefore, we don't have the same condition we're proposing that we did in the gross amount because they're right around the marker.
However, if that transfer of funds does not occur, then we would require their board, if they're approved, we would require the board to submit a new budget that shows them at the level of cash that they do receive.
So lastly, I just kind of want to walk through the governance structure of the charter school.
This was a little bit of a discussion at the main meeting, if you recall.
And so similar to one of the other ones, I'm just going to say the celerity schools, we talked a little bit about their governance structure.
And I didn't have any sort of handout.
We were doing like airbox drawings.
So I brought you an organization chart.
This was actually provided by the charter school.
So it is not something that we drafted.
and it is also in one of the attachments that's part of the item.
So the public was made available to this, but I've pulled it out because the attachments are so large, it would be hard for you to find it.
But this kind of gives you an idea of the governance structure that the Sweetwater School has in their petition, and you can actually visualize that.
So the Sweetwater petition states that Sweetwater shall be operated by Audeo Charter School Corporation, which is a California non-profit public benefit corporation pursuant to California law.
Audeo Charter School Corporation is organized and operated exclusively for educational and charitable purposes pursuant to and exclusively, excuse me, pursuant to and within the meaning of Section 501C3 of the Internal Revenue Code.
The corporation is responsible for Sweetwater's operational management and shall operate within the terms and conditions specified in the charter and its governing documents.
Sweetwater shall be governed by the Idea Charter School Corporation non-profit board of directors in accordance with its adopted corporate bylaws consistent with the terms of the charter.
All directors shall be designated by the existing board of directors.
So as you can see in the organization chart, Audeo Charter School Corporation currently operates two charter schools, both authorized by the state board.
One was approved in 2016, Audeo Charter School 2, and Grossmont Secondary School was recently authorized in May.
So that one is going to open in the fall and Audeo Charter School is going into its second year of operation.
So based on the discussion we had at the last meeting and there was an organization chart that was sort of handed out at the meeting and we could not authenticate that because it was not part of the charter petition for Grossmont nor was it something provided to you at that time by the petitioner.
So we actually reached out for clarity and for clarification to the Sweetwater petitioners to get some more information.
We ended up getting this organization chart as well as some other documents to look at their governance organizations associated with the corporation, Audeo Charter School Corporation, including the names and titles of officers for each of the schools and those organizations.
We find that the organization chart that's in front of you that's also in one of the attachments for Adeo Charter School Corporation reflects the governance structure that is outlined in the charter petition and in the governing documents.
However, in light of having recent discussions on some very complex governance structures we have seen in some other appeals that have been brought before you, we requested that additional information from the petitioner.
And we find that some of these documents provide evidence that Audeo Charter School Corporation has affiliations with other organizations, as you can see in the chart.
and also noted in our recommended conditions and that there are common officers among these organizations.
So as such, we felt that if the charter school is ultimately approved, we feel like the conditions we have proposed are prudent and also we hope that they serve a goal to provide additional means necessary for the department to provide effective and meaningful oversight of the charter school if it is approved.
So in summary, I just want to state that the petition is consistent with sound educational practice based on our review.
The petitioner is likely to implement the intended program and the petition provides a reasonably comprehensive description of the required elements, noting that some do require a technical amendment that we're proposing.
We recommend that the State Board hold a public hearing and approve the petition to establish Sweetwater under the oversight of the State Board with our conditions and technical amendments that we're recommending.
So I believe both the petitioner and I think the district is here to present to the Board and I'm here to answer any questions that you may have.
Yeah, we're going to have some technical questions first.
Board Member Holliday.
I'm sorry, Cindy.
Yeah, I have a technical question too.
Please stay.
Did you say that the ACCS voted unanimously?
Yeah.
I believe there was one.
It was 60.
I believe there was one member of the ACCS that voted no.
I just wanted to correct that for the record.
No, you're right.
I think it was Commissioner Washington.
Correct.
Hey, I have a question.
So we've been looking and we've had some prior hearings on this.
And so I'm looking at this chart and Mary Bixby is on Odeo Charter School Corporation.
She also is the president.
She's the president of Odeo.
She's the president of Student Success Programs Corporation.
My first question, are corporations are usually profit?
Are these for profit?
Secondly, and lastly, she is the President and CEO of Altus Mirus Inc., Incorporated.
That strikes me as usually profit if it's incorporated.
So, can you explain this relationships?
We've seen these in some prior ones and they've suggested issues.
And so, how does that, how does all this work?
what is a corporation in this case, who is Altus Mirus, and so on.
I'm going to go back and look at another document, but I believe that at least on Odeo Charter School Corporation, which is, this is the governance structure of the school, all of the schools that the State Board has approved.
That's a nonprofit public benefit corporation.
The other two student success programs, I believe, is as well.
We don't have information on Altus Muris.
That was one that we don't have any additional information.
able to get audit reports for Charter School San Diego and Odeo Charter School.
So it speaks a little bit to the governance of student success programs, but we don't have one for that third box, the green one, Altus Muris.
We don't have any information on that one.
And there were some recent changes that were noted.
I mean, the one thing we did look at that made it a little more complicated with some of the other petitions was this sort of sole statutory member that did exist at one point in these organizations.
But in early 2016, they did a corporate restructure.
and they remove that sole statutory member from their governance.
And so each one of these, aside from the Altus Muris, which I don't have your information, but it appears that Aldeo Charter School Corporation, Student Success Programs Corporation are now like separate entities that do not have another organization that's controlling them.
And that's based on the audit reports that we have for the schools.
The chartered petitioner may need to speak a little bit more about the different members.
There's not a lot of information other than what you see in the blue section for Audeo Corporation.
That is all laid out in their governance structure in the petition.
But how the interaction is with the other organizations, what we ended up getting from the additional request of documentations is there's a services agreement
where there's another organization that provides services, sort of like a contract, where they pay for the services and they provide
Research and Advocacy, Marketing and Licensing, Executive Coaching and Consultancy.
There's an agreement between Altus Institute, Student Success Programs, and Audeo, and then there was Altus Meris.
So that's the only other agreement, that's the only other affiliation we see, but this is a, again, a contractual sort of relationship between the organizations where the organizations
have contracted with the other ones to provide services.
So, but in terms of the membership, this was more recent and it was based more on this latest request of documentation we received.
So, not really sure how the members in the other organizations interact with this one.
But we did see that crossover of the same officers which led us to kind of have a little more robust condition in this item.
So we know we're asked to approve this with knowing very little about Altus Meris Incorporated.
I assume that's profit incorporation.
Usually to me implies profit.
We don't have any information on that one.
We couldn't get anything on that one.
Well, yeah, but it's a problem that we, to me, that, you know, we don't have this, you know, and we've seen people getting compensation across all three of these, which adds up to some pretty significant figures and so on.
I don't understand why we don't have information on this and board member Williams may want to comment.
He mistook us.
So, they are here to present and we can ask all of those questions.
My understanding is that at least Audeo Charter School Corporation, which is the group that oversees the charter schools,
that the two we've approved and the one that we're going to consider today is a non-profit public benefit corporation.
So the word corporation is throwing you off on that.
I think that's probably true on student success programs.
I don't know anything about Altus Marist, but that's why we have them here today to answer our questions.
Yeah, but this should be in the due diligence of the Department of Education.
I don't think it's a great idea to just have all of this done verbally at these meetings.
That's why we have a staff to investigate these things.
I don't understand why that isn't something we could read before we got here.
And we have to find out about these things through question and answer.
And then there's allegation and counter-allegation and so on.
I think given what we've been through, I would ask our liaisons to look into what we need to know about these various interlocking boards.
And the idea that these, you know, that these are, if I don't see the same people, I've got some questions.
But when I see the same people, and I've seen that in some other recent charter hearings we've had, that's what troubles me.
Okay, I will, the liaisons, the charter liaisons will ask for more of that information from CDE and State Board staff if we have that come up again.
I do know that at the ACCS meeting, all of those, which I observed on archive tape, member,
holiday was there, all of those questions seemed to be answered satisfactorily.
And I would, I appreciate your need for more information in advance.
On the other hand, I'd be careful myself, I'll be careful about carrying over from one set of charter schools concerns to another set without any reason, apparent reason to do so.
Well, I believe I'm speaking accurately here in that it's my impression that Altus Marist is a for-profit incorporated business.
It only has... I may be wrong.
But I believe that the purpose of Altus Marist is to provide these educational services for the various other charter schools.
But yeah, but evidently, there's some disagreement about whether it's for profit or not.
We'll find out.
Yeah, I'm wondering if we shouldn't be getting compensation data on these, you know, people on three different payrolls or whatever is going on.
You know, those are issues that, again, you know, I'm not trying to carry things over, but I think we need to learn from what
we have been learning as we go along here and that we, you know, we frankly approved some charter schools that we didn't know enough about, in my view.
So, and so I'm asking for expanded analysis of these interlocking relationships in that regard.
And I'm not sure the profit, non-profit is
the controlling thing as well, but I am interested in that as well.
Board Member Rucker.
Okay, so I'm going to begin by saying my reading comprehension skills are quite good and so I know that a Dale Charter School is not celerity, I understand that.
But if it looks like a duck and it quacks like a duck, it's not going to be a chicken.
So I also am concerned that there are three corporate officers for three different corporations that are the same.
And I also had questions about exactly what each of these organizations contract for.
But going beyond that, who makes the decisions about those contracts?
Who sets those rates?
And I'm not sure how to say this next question because there is a profit motive in making that decision.
Because then, who writes the contracts or who sets the agreements?
Are those agreements... I'm not sure what the correct legal term of art are.
But are the agreements simply a one-sided agreement where
because you are part of this large corporate family, I'm telling you this is how much you're going to hand to me for doing these services without consideration about whether that's the fair rate and all those things.
So, I do have a concern about the fact that there seems to be a common group of folks making some very important fiscal decisions that seem to accrue to the benefit not necessarily of the charter,
but to the corporation.
And none of this is very clearly spelled out.
These are some of the lessons we've learned from previous charters that we didn't know any of this information about.
But what I heard from the liaison is that these questions were answered.
So if the questions were answered, I'm kind of hoping somebody will tell me those answers today.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, we will have, so we'll open the public hearing and first we'll hear from the people who support the CDE recommendation to approve the charter petition.
You have 10 minutes.
Good morning state board members, CDE staff, and Superintendent Torlakson.
My name is Wade Ashbrenner.
I'm the lead petitioner.
I know you're burning to get some answers about the questions that have been posed and I'm going to allow a member of the development team, Christopher Carpenter, to discuss those.
So, to state for the fact and for the record completely, every organization that is affiliated with these schools are non-profit organizations.
They are 501c3 tax-exempt organizations that are subject to the California Nonprofit Integrity Act.
of 2004.
There are organizations that are subject to reporting standards to the IRS each year, providing Form 990s that are publicly available and that can be reviewed.
And each has now an independent board that makes and concludes any kind of financial decisions or major financial decisions that are made by a board.
There are common officers.
I will point out that Ms.
Jane Garonski has resigned as secretary of any of these schools.
Altus Mirus, Inc.
is a non-profit organization, 501c3 tax-exempt, and operates as simply an organization that operates the Mirus Secondary School, which is authorized by Hispera Unified School District.
The reason you don't see any information about Hysperia in this petition, in this application, is because it's an organization that is operating in a charter school authorized by Hysperia Unified and is not up on appeal.
The organization up on appeal and the school is up on appeal is Audeo Charter School, which is also a 501c3 nonprofit organization that has strict requirements regarding spending and things like that, including compensation requirements.
The Nonprofit Integrity Act of 2004 in California requires that every nonprofit organization with a gross income of over $2 million provide evidence of compensation committees and studies as to compensation of officers and key employees.
Those compensation studies are presented and provided to the state and often provided to the IRS as well as evidence that the
compensation is appropriate.
The compensation is set by an independent board of directors.
These board of directors consist of business owners, prior educators, other entrepreneurs in the area, members of the military, you'll see Admiral Len Herring,
on as a keyboard member.
There are shared officers.
The shared officers is essentially to keep the operational consistency across organizations.
One of the reasons, and I'm sure you'll hear from opposition that there's no need for all these different corporations.
Well, there is.
One of the reasons you have and set up a different nonprofit corporation, again, when I use the term corporation, I'm referring to a nonprofit
corporation that is required to submit information about the finances.
The reason you have these separate organizations is twofold.
One,
The structure that is in place now provides a clear view of the entire corporation's operation to each authorizer.
So, our DO charter school, all of its operations, if Sweetwater Secondary School is approved here, will be viewable by the State Board.
We also agree to all of conditions and the amendments requested by the State Board or by the staff.
We fully will comply with all of those.
We have no issue with it whatsoever.
We provided
every piece of information requested by the state office, and we are happy to provide as much as necessary.
We are not opposed at all to transparency.
The second reason why you have these separate organizations is essentially to reduce the potential for liability.
A non-profit corporation helps shield the school in case someone sues them.
If someone sues, say, Audeo Charter School 2, they can't get the assets of student success programs, or the charter school of San Diego, or a mere secondary school.
So those schools will not be put in danger because one person decides to sue one of the other schools.
That's the reason for these different corporations and why they're necessary.
It's not to hide anything.
It's not to provide any information or obfuscate the public.
I also want to make a point to notice that we have, that even Altus Institute, which I'm sure will come up from opponents, was an organization that was previously affiliated.
There is no more affiliation with that organization.
All contracts with them have been terminated.
It was a nonprofit corporation focused on charitable purpose of providing education to students and helping support charter schools.
But all contracts with them have been terminated.
There is no money flowing out from any of these schools to Altus Institute whatsoever.
Lastly, I just want to point out that before I allow
way to get back into the actual important stuff, which is the students and the educational program that this system provides to a very unique subset of students and the individualized education plan that's working for so many youth, that we have added a parent representative position to all of the boards of each of these organizations.
For Audeo Charter School, the board there has authorized and approved a parent representative position for them and is actively now recruiting.
for a parent representative.
So we are looking and actively seeking out ways to engage more with parents and more with the community and to provide more transparency.
With that, I'm going to turn it over to Wade so he can go through some of the actual information in the petition itself rather than the questions that have been popped up by
various org charts put around by different organizations or people that may not have reflected the actual organization.
President Kirst, was that an answer to your question or was that part of the public hearing?
That's an answer to the question.
I think we should start the 10 minutes and not preempt any of their planned presentation.
So I would begin now on the 10 minutes.
Let me see if I can... I declare the public hearing open.
Okay, we'll start at the beginning.
Again, I'm Wade Ashbrenner.
I'm the lead petitioner for the Sweetwater Secondary School.
First of all, I want to thank the CDE staff and the ACCS for their recommendation to approve this petition and also to recognize that it's not just me and Christopher Carpenter up here, but we have 60 members of the Sweetwater School community that are up here to show support for the petition.
And to give you a little background, it was working with our authorizer, San Diego Unified, that suggested to have the separate non-profits in order to provide further transparency to each of the... They didn't want schools not authorized by them under the non-profit that they authorized.
So that gives you a little historical perspective on that.
So in September of 2016, as the final piece of a larger compliance plan for the Charter School of San Diego, we submitted the petition for the resource centers located within the Sweetwater Union High School District so that we could adhere to what we were getting feedback about the Shasta decision as far as the location of resource centers outside a school district's boundary.
So we did submit prior to the final decision.
But the Sweetwater Secondary School will be comprised of three resource centers located within the boundaries of the Sweetwater Union High School District, of which the Plaza Bonita Resource Center has been serving families since the 2012-2013 school year.
You have a diagram here of the IDEO Charter School Corporation.
It is a nonprofit board and it will govern the Sweetwater Secondary School.
The board is directly responsible for the success of the charter schools it governs and is within the scope and oversight of the State Board of Education.
The IDEO board
further complies with the Brown Act in its meetings, the California Public Records Acts in its documents, and the Political Reform Act in its Conflict of Interest Code.
In fact, the Conflict of Interest Code was approved by the San Diego County Board of Supervisors.
For financial stability, the organization has disaggregated our financial data by resource center since the 2012-2013 school year and
they calculate a net result of operations for each resource center.
So in March 30th of 2017, Student Success Programs, which is the governing board for the Charter School of San Diego, passed a resolution to transfer the net result of operations for fiscal years 2013-14, 14-15, and 15-16, which
yields a little more than a million dollars to the Sweetwater Secondary School so that the money will follow the students so that that school can get up off to a great start.
So a little history about the Charter School of San Diego.
It was founded in 1994 and its financial and compliance audits have consistently found no exceptions and the school has earned 100% funding under SB 740 for multiple years.
Working with the San Diego Unified School District, they have issued a letter of good standing that the Charter School of San Diego has met all its financial obligations to its authorizer.
That letter of good standing was sent to Superintendent Janney.
Also, the charter petition was submitted to the Sweetwater Union High School District on September 27th of 2016, and we did not have a public hearing until November.
14th of that year, a full 48 days after submission.
So we did try to work with the district to have a timely petition process, but it did get quite lengthy.
And as a top performing alternative school,
Since 2011 to 2015, we have lowered our dropout rate for students in the South Bay, which has really caused an increase for the demand in our program, thus the addition of resource centers in the South Bay.
Since opening the Plaza Bonita Resource Center, you can see that there's been a growing student population of students served from the Sweetwater Union High School District.
The average for the past four years has been about 345 students.
We use a non-classroom based independent study program, and it's a proven model by the Charter School of San Diego.
We focus on students' individual strengths, values, and interests.
Our teachers share a culture of commitment to students and their success.
We are very proud to have Jeanette Perez as a member of the Charter School of San Diego.
She was recently named the 2017 California Charter School Teacher of the Year, and we're very proud to have her as a member of our organization.
In our non-classroom based instructional program,
Many students find our teachers to be both role model and mentors.
And we look for teachers who have a passion and commitment to help struggling students.
Our teachers, we've made a commitment to our teachers and we realize that success starts with them.
So we compensate them with a salary that's 5% above that of the San Diego Unified School District.
We provide 100% employer paid benefits to the employee and to all eligible employee dependents.
Over the past three years, our teacher retention rate has been over 90%, and 60% of our teachers have been with us more than six years.
We have a tremendous relationship for professional development with the San Diego County Office of Education.
And in the past two years, our teachers have attended over 7,000 hours of training from the Leadership and Learning Division of San Diego County Office of Education.
We also have internal professional development where we grow future leaders.
So many of the people, including myself, have worked their way up through the ranks of the Charter School of San Diego into leadership positions.
To date, 87 teachers have received their Leading Edge certification as a result of our partnership with the San Diego County Office of Ed.
Leading Edge certification is a national certification program in educational technology and curriculum innovation.
But at the heart of our program is our students and transforming lives is our mission.
We've designed a rigorous academic curriculum to prepare students for life after high school.
Students, parents and staff collaborate to create a personalized academic plan to complete their high school and transition to perhaps a four-year university or community college or enter directly into their career.
Student demographic trends indicate that about 65% of our students in middle and high school come to us credit deficient by more than one semester.
So I know yesterday you talked about alternative assessment measures for those schools, so I commend you that programs like ours do need some alternative metrics to prove their success.
70% of our students are socioeconomically disadvantaged.
84% represent minority student populations.
Additionally, approximately 19% of our students currently qualify for special education support.
And overall, for the Charter School of San Diego, 15% of our students are English language learners.
We designed a program of pathways to achieve student success.
The data that we collect shows that when teachers and students have one-on-one support, that students develop a confidence in their abilities, leading them to personal successes few had had before.
The focus of the Sweetwater Secondary School will be to improve student learning, offer a safe learning environment, and provide a highly qualified faculty and staff to an often high-risk student population.
Over the past five years alone, the Charter School of San Diego has had more than 3,000 students complete their high school requirements.
A big part of our program
is our ELD program or English Language Development.
The Sweetwater Secondary School will offer a comprehensive ELD program.
The integrated portion of the program is designed to ensure that our English learners can access the core curriculum, build the literacy skills that they need to engage in a rigorous course of study that is aligned to California Common Core standards.
All courses are customized and based on the student's skill level and interests.
Curriculum is scaffolded and language supports are embedded in each course.
Teachers are trained on research-based engagement strategies, including SDI.
We have a nationally recognized program.
The Charter School of San Diego is one of the oldest charter schools in operation.
It was founded in 1994.
We were fortunate in 2015 that we were awarded
the Malcolm Baldrige National Equality Award.
Under President Obama, it's the nation's highest presidential honor for performance excellence through innovation, improvement, and visionary leadership.
This was the first time that the award was presented to a single school, much less than a charter school in the Baldrige Award's 29-year history.
Sorry, that was a...
Some of our accomplishments.
Just two weeks ago, we were notified by WASC that the Charter School of San Diego was awarded a six-year clear WASC accreditation term and has comprehensive course lists approved by both the University of California and the NCAA.
The school was able to achieve the 23rd highest API score while it was under its ASAM designation out of approximately 850 alternative schools.
We take great pride in the fact that we just had recently had 394 students take part in graduation in Balboa Park down in San Diego.
It's a beautiful setting and I invite everyone on the board to come down and join us for graduation next year.
And finally, to the more than 300 students who signed our online petition, additionally I have two of these containers of postcards for over a thousand parents.
who have supported the school throughout its duration.
We're just happy to have a community that supports us and agrees that there needs to be public school options for some of the most disadvantaged students in the community, gives them an opportunity to re-engage with their studies, have a safe school environment, and have a personalized education plan.
I know you take great care when rendering a decision, and I urge you to recommend this charter school petition for approval.
Thank you very much.
Do we have any more time?
I just wanted to make one.
I still have some time?
OK, great.
Again, I wanted to express my appreciation to Superintendents Torlakson and Board President Kurz, the rest of the board members for hearing this.
This is the last one of these petitions of this school to come up before you.
You have authorized already ACS2, Audio Charter School 2, and Grossmont Secondary School petitions that have come before you.
And as this is the same model of program,
you know, it's already been determined that the program is educationally sound and meets the requirements of Education Code section 47605B.
So we do hope that you approve this petition.
If there are any questions regarding any of the makeup or things like that that may come up later on, I'm happy to answer those questions and we look forward to your vote.
Thank you.
Okay, now the opponents of the charter petition and CDE recommendation, please come forward.
You will have 10 minutes.
Good morning, board members.
It's my pleasure to be in front of you this morning.
With me here today is Dr. Joe Falcher, who is the Assistant Super Equity, Culture and Support Services for Sweetwater Union High School District.
Gene Shavira, who is the CTA president representing classified and certificated staff.
And also Jenny Carbuccia, who is a general counsel for Sweetwater.
My name is Sarah Sutherland.
I represented Sweetwater Union High School District in consideration of this petition.
This is not a new charter school being proposed to you for any of the enumerated reasons in the Charter Schools Act.
It is a corporate expansion effort to generate more revenue and profit for the corporate executives who are making quite a substantial profit off this endeavor by duplicating identical programs and avoiding transparency.
and the sound fiscal practices that are required when spending public tax dollars on public education.
Petitioners have not been cooperative at the local level.
All of the information that was provided to you about all these various corporations were not provided or mentioned in the petition.
I think that's very significant.
This issue is now before you and has become the main issue because we did our research in considering the petition and knew that this wasn't just one school being started, but a part of a vast network of interrelated contracts, common boards, and common executives.
The CDE proposes technical amendments and conditions.
They are not technical amendments and conditions.
They are proposals to remedy flaws in the charter petition that form the basis for denial at the local level.
These are not technical amendments.
These are adding people to the board, changing corporate descriptions.
This is a very different petition that we're talking about today than it was in October when the Sweetwater board first looked at this.
The petition is not transparent, nor is the operations of this organization that has multiple layers of corporations that are all related and affiliated and contract with one another.
The petition does not disclose the Greater Altus Network or how the school is governed overall, who is making the decisions, with what profit, with what motives in mind, where they're meeting.
It explains how this impacts your oversight, what happens if
$500,000 or $1 million or $1.5 million is transferred from this school to another expansion effort.
Do you all get to oversee that or not?
It's unclear.
The petition failed to mention the simultaneous application to Groshmont.
It would be served by the same governing board.
The petition had identical language, yet CDE's findings and conditions are different.
at your very next board meeting.
The petition proposes a new program specifically tailored to Sweetwater community.
The petition was identical to the petition for Audeo II, Grosmont Secondary School, and other Altus schools, showing that it's really more of a franchise of an existing product.
It's not a plan developed for the Sweetwater community with the Sweetwater community's needs in mind.
Sweetwater is a much different community than Grosmont, than San Diego, and has different
considerations and they don't have a parent on the board.
They're still not entitled to a parent on the board.
That's a condition you all put on the Grossmont Secondary School.
And so while I'm glad to see that's now happening, that was not something that was proposed to the Sweetwater Board.
That was not something that was being considered at the local level.
That was one of the basis for denial at the local level was the lack of participation of the local community in this charter school.
There is also a huge problem with conflicts of interest and excessive pay.
There's been a lot of dialogue about for-profit versus non-profit corporations.
Non-profit corporations still pay their executives a lot of money.
It just means the corporation doesn't have a profit that it pays.
And so all charter schools in this vast network, including the Altus Marist, are run centrally, but it's not written that way.
They don't exist under the oversight of anyone.
Each of the little corporations under the big corporation is overseen by individual agencies.
This can be seen by the fact that executive employees are paid disproportionately gross salaries in comparison to what they're doing.
According to the Altus tax records, Mary Bixby earned a salary of $371,160 in 2015.
That was to serve 3,000 kids in independent study.
$371,000.
That was not disclosed.
That was not said publicly.
That's not in your materials.
That is higher than nearly all district superintendents in the entire state.
That was 2015.
I suspect it's higher now.
They need to keep growing to increase and keep corporate salaries at that level.
This is not what public educators get paid.
Academic performance, I will allow others to speak to that, but suffice it to say, it is not what they indicate that it is.
And Sweetwater schools, same type of students, are consistently outperforming these resource centers.
Lastly, I already mentioned this, but the lack of parent involvement is very, very significant because it is unclear which board is making decisions and where they're meeting.
And every one of these boards has common members and common executives.
And so there is substantial, they are not arm's length transactions, as Member Rucker was referring to earlier.
They are two people on the same side deciding we'll transfer 10% of this revenue to provide consulting and some of those other services that were listed that really have nothing to do with educating kids and have to do with expanding a corporation.
My name is Joe Fulcher.
I'm the Assistant Superintendent of Equity, Culture, and Support Services for the Sweetwater School District.
I've had a 25-year educational career.
I've been a teacher assistant, worked in a children's center, teacher, school counselor, school psychologist, principal, director of special ed.
been a Chief Student Services Officer and now an Assistant Superintendent.
And I mention my history because I've had a long career of championing and implementing very effective programs.
I have a strong track record of putting programs that have served students across this state
and take issue with the fact that someone recommended approval of this because it's a sound program, a sound educational program.
I know it's extremely rare for school board members to go against the recommendation of their staff, but in this case, I think it makes sense.
This charter and petition lacks in several ways.
Some you've heard about already and others I'll briefly mention.
Our district, the Sweetwater School District, was found in 1920.
We are on the border, the international border.
We serve almost 80% of our students, rather, are Latino.
The next largest population are Asian students, followed by white and African American.
Many of the staff in our district, 80% of the staff in our district attended school in Sweetwater.
It's a strong, viable community.
The academic performance that you heard about from Altus does not replicate what we do for the students in our district.
Their academic performance is a little lower than the students we serve across the board.
Their graduation rate
It's lower and their dropout rate is higher.
So we think our program is a substantial improvement to what you've heard about or read about in some of the documents you've received.
They talked about a plan for their students with English, who are English learners.
If you look deep and dig deeper into that plan, you'll see there's a lack of coherence.
It's not really a plan at all.
We have a long track record in Sweetwater of serving students, all students, but especially students who are learning English.
Over 50% of our students are in that category as of this year.
Their education program, which they mentioned a few times, lacks rigor, in our opinion.
And we say this after considerable research and investigation into their program.
It won't necessarily increase or improve the academic achievement.
And it's modeled after other programs with different populations of students served.
the participation AP classes and A through G courses is much lower than what we offer the students in our district.
So I would sit here and actually commit to serving and supporting this program if I thought it would make a substantial difference for the students in our district.
I don't think it will.
And I'm recommending you reject this petition.
Blue Board members.
I'm Gene Shavira, a special education teacher, president of the Sweetwater Education Association, and a lifelong resident of the Sweetwater Union High School district and graduate, proud graduate.
I'm here today as a representative of the teachers and all of the Sweetwater CSEA members to urge you to deny Sweetwater Secondary Schools' petition for charter.
As a special education teacher, I have concerns on the impact that Sweetwater Secondary School have on special education programs at the Sweetwater Union High School District.
When corporate charter schools siphon general ed students from public schools, they impact the ratios of
special ed to general ed students in public schools.
Because of the unique social economic status of Sweetwater Union High School District, it has a high percentage of special ed students and recently received a letter from the state to try to lower the number.
when special education students are accepted, they are often not served properly.
A recent case within the Altus Charter School, the parent company of the Sweetwater Secondary Schools, $47,000 in unknown attorney fees were awarded to a special education student for their failure to be placed in appropriate educational setting as required by federal law.
I urge you again to deny the petition.
I know it's done but our assemblywoman Lorena Gonzalez who represents the entire district has also submitted a letter of opposition that was going to be read to you that talks about the issues that she has related to transparency.
Thank you.
Okay.
I now declare the public hearing closed and ready for initial comments by board members and questions.
We could...
We could also proceed directly to public comment if people want to.
Do either the liaisons want to comment now or should we go to public comment?
I know Board Member Rucker wants to comment, but I want to give the liaisons first shot.
Okay, Board Member Rucker.
Yeah, okay.
All right, let's call a roll on the public comment.
Would the following people please line up?
Sarah Sutherland, Joni Carbuena, Stephanie Starr, Sue Fuller, Daisy Rodriguez, Dave Goyette, Javier Alonso, Becky Diaz,
Sebastian Salgado, Cameron Walton, Arlene McGowan, Esteban Salgado, Jeanette Perez, Satupu Sagano, Jean Chirira, Michelle Lynch, David Cortez, Lorraine Richards, and Eric Primack.
Hello, my name is Stephanie Starr.
I'm the Special Instructional Services Coordinator and member of the development team for Sweetwater Charter School.
I'd like to tell you a little bit about some of our student subgroups.
We excel at serving students with disabilities and English learners because we tailor our instructional program to the unique needs of each and every student.
Our program design allows us to truly customize teaching and learning, and it's really exciting work.
We currently serve a 15% English learner population.
These are students that enroll with us at ages 16 and older.
They're already classified as English learners, and they're at high risk of becoming long-term.
We have a proven, demonstrated success with moving these students towards English proficiency and reclassification.
We also have a 19% special education population.
Again, these are students that enroll older and have already been identified.
And to serve them, we will become a part of the El Dorado County Charter SELPA.
Thank you.
Please support our petition.
Hello, my name is Susan Fuller, the grandmother and guardian of Cameron Fuller, a senior at the Charter School of San Diego.
CSSD's staff and services have changed the direction of Cameron's educational experience from hopeless to being able to see the light at the end of the tunnel.
At her previous school, it became clear during eighth grade we needed guidance as a family.
The school was just too large for Cameron, and after two years of IEPs, counselor assistance, she was exhausted and made little progress.
In 11th grade, Cameron enrolled at CSSD, where we discovered a feeling of partnership, genuine concern for her future, and a willingness to help her with her unique needs.
Our granddaughter's goal with the continued support of her teachers is to attend City College and enroll in their cosmetology program.
Thanks to CSSD, the dedicated teachers, and their specialized programs, Cameron's true potential has been unlocked.
Please vote to approve Sweetwater's charter.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Daisy Rodriguez.
I'm currently a student enrolled at CSSD and soon to be graduate.
Ever since I began attending the Charter School of San Diego, it has given me the opportunity to become a more independent individual and to interact more with my instructors.
They are very attentive when needed, are always open to working with my schedule, and keep me focused on my work.
At first, I didn't believe I could take on independent studies because of the lack of determination.
Fortunately, my instructor was very encouraging and I gained a lot of confidence in myself.
The help given has been very beneficial and convenient for me.
The lessons are very clear, understandable, and I have noticed a big difference in my grades.
I ask for you to please approve this petition so that other students can get on the path to success as well.
Thank you for your time.
Hello, my name is David Goyette.
I'm a teacher with the Charter School of San Diego, and I'm proud to speak to you today in support of the Sweetwater Secondary Petition.
In my 18 years as a teacher, I've seen firsthand how some traditional schools and charter schools struggle to support their instructional staff and students.
By contrast, our CSSD support staff and professional development team ensure that our teachers have all the tools and training to guide their students towards success.
CSSD teachers are compensated 5% above the local district's pay scale.
Our generous benefits package gives our teachers and families peace of mind and our classrooms are well equipped with the latest technology and materials.
As a teacher who began
As a classroom assistant with the program and served as a teacher representative on our school's board of directors, I can attest to the robust support our teachers receive every day.
I'm thankful to be part of an organization that honors its teachers so we can put our students first.
Please vote to approve.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Javier Alonzo, and I am a graduate of the Charter School of San Diego.
My experience with this program was nothing short of amazing.
At the Charter School of San Diego, I was inspired by the adaptive learning environment.
And for the first time in my life, I actually looked forward to waking up and going to school.
This school welcomed me with open arms, and I had teachers there that showed me that they wanted all their students to be there and succeed beyond their dreams.
Like all students, myself, there was a time where I got a lack of motivation and a lot of work left, and I didn't want to do anything.
But with this school's help and passion, I was able to make the deadline to graduate with them in their recent ceremony.
Simply to put it, it is a flexible program that has incredible teachers that make it a life-changing experience for me and all students.
It is simply, really, the greatest experience of my life.
And I would recommend this program to any student that needs something different, a different learning environment to their own pace.
Please approve the Sweetwater Secondary School.
We won't let you down, I promise.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Rebecca Diaz, and I've grown up and raised my own family in the Sweetwater community, specifically in the East Lake Bonita area, where many of my students and families come from.
I've been fortunate enough to teach at the Charter School of San Diego for the past nine years, and I feel very privileged to speak to you today.
I witnessed the many successes of our students who come to us for different reasons.
For example, some students attend our school because they're behind on credits or they're below grade level in reading and math.
And we offer them a personalized, individualized approach to learning that includes working on one course at a time and one-on-one and in small group settings.
Because of the low student to teacher ratio, I am able to build a personal rapport with my students.
And this provides them with a sense of security and belonging, which leads to greater learning outcomes.
It also allows us to foster students who will one day be active citizens and future leaders within the Sweetwater community.
I urge you to approve the Sweetwater Secondary Schools Charter.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Sebastian Salgado and I attended the Charter School of San Diego from which I proudly graduated.
In traditional high school, due to my unique learning style, I struggled having new teachers with each subject.
Their teaching styles and approaches often made it pretty difficult for me.
Ultimately, I found it hard to build a solid relationship with them, which hindered my academic progress.
The Charter School of San Diego was a much better option for me because I had one teacher at a time.
And with that, as a result, they got to know my learning style.
It was very easy for me to adapt to this program, and I benefited from its flexibility.
It also helped that I encountered peers who were a positive influence on me compared to others who had a negative influence on me.
Now, I'm doing great.
I'm attending a local community college.
I'm working and I do volunteer work.
I hope that you please approve the Sweetwater Secondary School petitions so that the students can get to the path as well.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Cameron Walton and I'm a graduate from the Charter School of San Diego.
I came to the Charter School of San Diego because I wanted to go to a school where I could work at my own pace and create a structure of learning that worked for me.
The Charter School of San Diego also allowed me more time to spend with my family.
which I needed to do due to severe health problems my dad was experiencing the past year.
The Charter School of San Diego gave me the opportunity to have a flexible schedule, be there with my dad, and worked very closely with me to make sure my life and family needs were being met while still succeeding in school.
At the Charter School of San Diego, I did outstanding compared to how I did at my previous school.
I went from getting C's to straight A's at the Charter School of San Diego.
The improvement in my grades opened up many doors for my future.
The Charter School of San Diego also helped in preparing me for college by having me create my college plan and a whole college presentation.
I'm going to attend San Diego Mesa Community College, and I hope to become an automotive mechanic.
Please approve Sweetwater's charter, which will help give more students like me the opportunity to thrive in school and plan for the future.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
My name is Arlene McGowan, and I am the data and assessment coordinator and also a member of the development team for Sweetwater Secondary School.
First, I would like to thank the CDE staff for the work they've done in support of alternative educational settings and the board's unanimous approval yesterday on the eligibility criteria for schools that serve unique student populations like ours.
As an alternative schools accountability model school, in comparing with similar ACM schools in the Sweetwater Union High School District, we do outperform those schools in dropout rates, graduation rates, smarter balance assessment.
Results in English Language Arts and Math in both school-wide results and special student groups.
And then also our English learners' performance on this CELT.
We do have that comparable data here, and we can make it available upon request.
We ask you to please approve our Sweetwater secondary school petition.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Estel Salgado, and I am a student at the Charter School of San Diego, and I'm speaking today in favor of the Sweetwater Secondary School petition.
Starting in elementary school, I tried to focus on my academic work, but many of my classmates were already getting into trouble, which I found easily distracting.
Since I wanted to direct my attention towards school and stay away from the negative influences, I enrolled in the Charter School of San Diego.
Here, I'm thriving.
I'm doing very well academically and can focus all of my attention on my studies.
I'm getting ahead in all my classes and I have all A's and B's.
The big difference I have found in this program helps me to stay on track and learn at my own pace, which I find really supportive and helps me to understand the material.
I ask that you please approve of this petition so that other students may benefit from this program as well.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Jeanette Perez and I've just started my 24th year at the Charter School of San Diego as a teacher.
I've seen firsthand the opportunities that our school offers students so they can be successful, productive citizens.
In June, many of my students became the first to graduate in their family.
This has been the case for hundreds of my students.
Another student who has been homeless for most of her life just earned her high school diploma.
Unfortunately, this type of situation is not outside the norm for our student population.
The design, resources, and special training we are provided at CSSD allows us to meet these students' needs and move them forward.
In fact, in March, I was honored to receive the 2017 Hart Dungeon Award.
Please support the Grossmont Charter.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Saitupu L. Sangyal and I am a proud graduate of the Charter School of San Diego.
I've attended the Charter School of San Diego since the sixth grade due to the fact that I was an extremely shy kid and my mom wanted me to go to a safer alternative for school.
But the Charter School of San Diego didn't just benefit my safety.
It also gave me the opportunity to gain leadership skills.
I participated in the California Cadet Corps, where I was able to push myself outside of my comfort zone and grow as a leader.
I even competed in a statewide academic competition and won first place, earning the highest competitive award in the program.
Without the Charter School of San Diego, my accomplishments wouldn't have been possible.
The teachers understand that not all children learn the same way or go through the same things.
Though it may not seem like it at times, we as kids appreciate this more than anything else.
The Charter School of San Diego has been a door opener for many kids and the last door opened for some.
Please approve the Sweetwater Secondary Schools Charter so that the children in this community are able to grow and succeed no matter what obstacles they face.
Thank you.
Hello, Lorraine Richards, excuse me, Lorraine Richards, California Teacher Association.
The petition was denied locally by both the Board of Trustees and the San Diego County Board of Education, and we urge you to do the same.
The concerns are transparency that includes the central operations of the Altus Charter Network,
governance and educational equality, lack of parent participation in governance, and disproportionately high compensations, uphold the denial of the Altus-operated Sweetwater Education, excuse me, Secondary School.
If the State Board of Education upholds the denial of this petition, the Sweetwater Secondary School is free to adjust their petition and resubmit, allowing the local school district to maintain oversight in the interests of the local community that they represent.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter School Center.
We have a 24-year track record of very sound operations financially, instructionally, so on and so forth.
We strongly support the petition.
Also would remind you that when the petitioners came forward at a prior meeting, board member Burr, who I hope is playing a nice round of golf today, also noted her experience with the petitioners going on long back into charter history.
So I hope you'll support.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Michelle Lynch on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
I'll echo Eric's comments.
We have a very long history with this organization and we are very confident in their ability to implement this program.
We would ask today that you support their petition.
Thank you.
Thank you, ladies and gentlemen of the board.
Paul Minney, legal counsel for the Charter School.
The interlocking officers here is not a detriment.
In fact, it's a huge benefit, as Eric said.
These are the same officers that have been operating the Charter School of San Diego successfully for over 20 years, as you heard, with clean audits, multiple renewals, which are quite extensive at San Diego Unified School District, governance awards like the Malcolm Baldrige Award.
These are high integrity officers that are operating this nonprofit public benefit corporation.
To be clear, all operations of the charter school are subject to all state's transparency laws, all the Brown Act, Public Records Act, all state's conflicts of interest laws.
And unlike some of the other charter schools we've recently reviewed, all charter schools operations are open to the public.
There's no for-profit corporations.
There's no common board members as you've heard from legal counsel from Sweetwater.
This is not an expansion effort.
Petitioners did exactly what Sweetwater demanded in litigation against other charter schools that are operating within their boundaries.
Petition locally.
They did that.
They did that before Anderson because the San Diego Unified School District required all charter schools operated by Charter Schools San Diego to petition locally if they were operating outside their district boundaries.
This is a simple conversion of an existing successful program.
Thank you.
So once again, this is an existing
charter school in the sense that it is a conversion based upon the law now of a portion of the San Diego Charter School.
I do believe that the petitioners have stepped up over the course of the past few months as we've heard previous petitions from them to continue to try to impress upon all of us that transparency is their goal and that they are trying to serve students well.
And when the time comes, I would move that we recommend the staff recommendation.
Thank you.
I do have some questions I wanted to ask, but I don't want to begin, if I could, with the representatives for the charter school.
Okay, so first of all, let me just say that unlike, I have come to look at these petitions and these appeals to the board, especially when they are so contentious, with a jaundiced eye.
Because usually when the petitions are approved after such contention with a great deal of controversy, I find out later on that there were things that I should have known
that I did not know and that's happened several times in very public ways at this board meeting.
So I have some questions for you about some things I think are important for me to know.
I want to make sure I understand in this organizational chart that I have and thank you for providing it.
In the organizational chart I have, it is your clear explanation that these three different charter organizations, these three different corporations are separate and independent.
Is that correct?
Yes.
Okay, so when you were going through and giving some examples about the performance and the success of your students, what I didn't hear, I heard a lot about San Diego, but what I didn't hear was about the other two charter schools that are directly under your responsibility and about what is going on with those charters.
What I've heard from the attorney who represents your charter is that there's 24 years of success for the charter and that includes a number of renewals.
But the other charters that are under your direct responsibility were only approved by the board and that's the thing that all three of these charters
seem to have in common.
Can you tell me why there was such a contentious problem at the local level and the county office level, given the success you've had with getting other charters approved in two other districts?
What do you feel was the problem that seems to be common among these three charters?
And I don't mean to make that a pointed question, even though I recognize it is.
I'm trying to understand, given the success you have with charters that have been locally authorized, what seems to be the problem with these three?
The three you're referring to?
Dale Charter School 2, Grosvenor Secondary and now Sweetwater Secondary.
If I may.
Well, it's impossible on the first part for us to speak on behalf of any of the school districts who denied these petitions.
But you know what you were told, so I want to understand what seems to be common among these three schools, in your opinion.
I am asking for your opinion.
My opinion is that these school districts are trying to claw back ADA, plain and simple.
That's the issue.
There are political forces at issue here that have nothing to do with students, unfortunately.
These programs have been, were previously operated by the charter schools.
You can stop.
Okay.
Well, no, I'm not done.
All right.
So, here's my next question.
So, can you tell me
What is the average, what is the experience level, the range of experience with your certificated staff?
Who's the, how long have they been employed by your corporation?
Well, as I stated earlier, 60% of the teachers have been with us more than six years, and only 15% have been with us three years or less.
Okay, so those are numbers.
That could be you have 10 teachers employed.
So that, yeah.
So the numbers I'm working off would be a total of 64 teachers, 39 of which are six years or greater with the organization, the Charter School of San Diego.
And who made the decision to hire those teachers?
Those are senior leadership through, we have a hiring process.
That's a three-step process.
So the board for this corporation made the decision?
Ultimately, they're made by the senior leaders of this corporation.
Okay.
And the employment agreement, is that, who is that developed by?
It's developed by senior leadership, HR, internal HR, and legal counsel.
And is it fair to say that the employment agreement that you have is an employment agreement unique to your corporation or is it similar to the employment agreement for the other two corporations listed on this chart?
I'm a bit confused by the question.
Can you repeat it?
So you have a contract for the certificated employees you've hired.
You told me that it was approved and developed.
These people were hired by your corporation, by the senior leadership of your corporation.
I'm asking who wrote the employment agreement.
The employment agreement was written by the corporation's senior staff, the HR, internal HR of the corporation in conjunction with legal counsel.
Okay, then my second question is, was this, is this employment agreement the same employment agreement for the other two corporations?
Yes.
So how was that employment agreement approved by the other two corporations?
Let me rephrase my answer.
My answer is that the form and the terms are the same.
They are not the same contract.
So if a person is, if a teacher, a certificated teacher is going to teach at Audeo Charter School 2, they are going to be employed by Audeo Charter School Corporation, receive their pay from Audeo Charter School Corporation, and have a contract with Audeo Charter School Corporation.
But the contract itself is the same for all three corporations?
for the most part, in terms, payment, those kinds of things to provide operational consistency.
Do the teachers who are employed and approved for service by your corporation teach students or have contact online with students from any of these other schools?
No.
Okay.
And I'm assuming you receive federal funds like from the Elementary and Secondary Education Act.
Who wrote that school plan?
be members of the senior leadership team.
And since there is a requirement for parents whose children attend this school to participate as stakeholders in writing that plan, how were parents included?
So we had various opportunities through open house nights, through working sessions on the school plan, through surveys directed to parents.
And how were teachers that were employed by your corporation included for writing that school plan?
Hi, I'm Stephanie Starr.
We do have a school site councils that are charged with the development of the school site plan, LEA plan.
I'm not asking about the LCAP.
I'm asking about the plan that was submitted.
The single school plan for student achievement for our intensive purposes.
That is this one in the same as the LEA plan, which is different than the LCAP.
OK, I understand.
And so for this plan, are there three different plans that were submitted for each corporation?
Yes.
All right.
Okay, thank you.
So in reviewing this, when did this structure come to be?
When did this become all of the schools under Odeo and student success programs?
There was a reorganization in January of 2016.
Of 2016?
Because as I Google your schools and the CEO's message, it always references Altus as the company or the organization of which all of these fall under.
And I Googled all of them.
Altus is a name that gets thrown around a lot.
That was a, if you will, brand name, essentially, a way to tie the information and the educational program between all the schools when looking at recruiting students and things like that.
It does not indicate necessarily a connection to the other entity.
It does not indicate a direct relationship or ownership at all at this time.
So then you need to update all of your websites.
So is there anything that could still possibly be integrated?
Monies, programs, contracts that may still be integrated because of the structure you once had?
And I can answer that question actually conclusively, and that is no.
The Altus Institute is actually, I believe, and they have counsel here actually to answer questions that they are asked, but my understanding is that they are looking at dissolving that organization because these schools are operating in compliance with law and are independent.
But there are no contracts between the two organizations.
There is no money that will flow to that organization.
And the contract that was in existence for the previous year was extended prior to its end date by both organizations, students by Audio Charter School Corporation and Altus Institute prior to its term date, which was June 30th, because
These schools had become independent.
They had been operating for a year, at least the student success programs in Audea Charter School 2.
And then we were hopeful for approval here, which would have concluded the charitable purpose of those organizations.
Jeff, I just want to follow up on that.
Is this your current chart?
And did you hand this out to us?
This is the current chart.
And this is what we included to the CDE.
We brought it to the CDE.
And this was provided to you by CDE.
We did not hand that out to you.
The department did.
We crafted and submitted it to the department, yes.
And it's now, this is a current, this is the current setup.
That has been the setup since January 2016.
Pardon?
Okay.
I'm just getting clear where this, you submitted to the department, the department gave it to us.
Right.
Okay.
I'm just trying to figure out, make sure where this came from.
Other board member comments or questions?
So just really to our liaisons.
So this is concerning to me because we've been dealing with all different kinds of structure.
My belief from the students is that they're getting good support for alternative programs to meet their particular needs.
So I appreciate the students coming and for the parents who talked about what the program is doing for them.
So for me, it's not about the support that they're getting.
It's about this
these structures.
And we've seen them before and they're complicated.
I just wonder if ACCS and the liaisons had gone through this.
Again, it's a unique to this setting and it's really not reflecting the quality.
I'm just more interested in the organization and why all these different structures.
So over the years, there have been a number of charter organizations that have had complicated governance systems.
And they have, from time to time, created concern in people's minds because it's difficult to go through the connections and understand very clearly, transparently, who's on first and who's on second.
The thing that makes me feel comfortable about this situation is that, first of all, we're dealing with a
an organization that has run a very successful charter school for a very long time, and it's provided very good services for the young people.
I do believe that when you compare Apples to Apples, that their credit recovery program, that their individualized attention is serving students very well.
To their credit, I do believe that they are proactive about what is changing in terms of clarification of the law and resource center locations and all that.
And they were ahead of the game in terms of trying to solve that problem and spare their kids from disruption in their educational program.
I also think they've been proactive in trying to clarify and make more streamlined, if you will.
their organizational structure in an effort to prove transparently what they believe all along, and that has been that there's no wrongdoing, there's no behind-the-scenes hanky-panky, but instead it is simply clearly laid out now.
And this reorganization didn't happen in December or November.
This reorganization happened in January of 2016, and although there
Google may be not catching up very fast and maybe their websites certainly need to be, I know, and their websites haven't caught up.
And there's still a lot to do in those sorts of ways.
I do believe that the organizational chart that they have shown us that came through the CDE is the correct organizational chart.
And what we're really doing is we're
If we approve, we're approving this portion of the San Diego Charter School conversion into the Sweetwater Charter School, and that's why I would approve it.
So, I hear the concerns and I think I've made a comment at one of the previous meeting that I'm an old-fashioned charter school person.
So, I don't understand charter schools that have these corporations and parent corporations and all of these.
However, in this case, I do see this chart is very, very helpful.
It's very clear that there is a corporation for those charters authorized under the State Board.
Another one for those authorized under
San Diego Unified School District and another one for Hesperia Unified School District.
And I can see the rationale for that.
You're dealing with different authorizers.
So you want a corporate, you want a government body to deal in those different ways.
So it's very clear.
Now,
The website needs to catch up with this, clearly.
And I think the concern is the transparency of if a parent or someone from the public wanted to know information, how do they know where to go?
So that's just, that's something that's technical that they can fix.
But if this is true, this is the true corporation, then I don't have an issue with this.
And keep in mind that by corporation it's a non-profit 501c3.
It's not corporate as in, you know.
Yes.
Yeah, I think part of the issue we're facing here is a number of people, including me, are not familiar with how nonprofits are organized and governed that much.
And I know you've run a nonprofit and so on, but I've studied government and written books on the politics of governance, but we never got into nonprofit private organizations.
And I don't even understand why some are tax exempt and others pay, file with IRS and all that stuff.
So it's, you know, the board here is struggling to understand, at least I am, I should speak for, exactly what these organizations are like.
And we're really, I particular, I'm just lacking in the basics of the governance system that we're operating.
To your point, sir, I've worked in nonprofits only.
Yeah, worked in only government.
Right.
And so and this sort of approach and the way they've set it up with these independent boards is certainly something that's done.
Yeah, I agree, it's common.
It's just we're trying to educate ourselves, not that we object.
I'm just trying to understand it better in that regard.
Stanford's a nonprofit, but we don't have a lot of third party things and affiliates.
Not boards.
It all goes back to a board of trustees.
There is no alternative board at Stanford other than the Stanford Board of Trustees.
And I think UC really ends up at the Regents.
So these are pretty, the universities are not the same, I would think, as anything like this.
And they're operating in different school districts.
You know, we're a unified university.
I'm just trying to grasp this a little bit better.
And because it's become such a complex issue.
Board Member Rucker.
did have some questions, but I do want to say having gone through, I asked the questions pointedly that I asked of the representatives from the Audeo Charter School, primarily because they actually do operate, in my opinion, based on the evidence that I saw, they do operate and seem to have
a single overriding board of directors because I looked at the single plan for student achievement for all three corporations.
And in the good old days when we had all those consultants who were going to schools and writing these school improvement plans and they had a template and simply filled in the blank on those plans, that's how those plans read.
So somebody
had to contract for and develop and write not only those single plans but the employment agreements as well as each of the plans that were written for them to address any of the applications for the categorical programs and funds that they were currently used.
They read like a template document and they read like a cut and paste document.
So somebody approved and crafted that.
So they are operating
as a single entity under somebody's umbrella.
These are the things I'm saying that when we have these kind of controversies, I find them out later after we approve them that this is what the reality was.
More, I believe, more what I read on the website than what I read in this document.
But I do have some questions for the district representatives as well.
Everyone else had to make a 1.30 flight, but I stayed.
Hopefully, I can answer your questions.
I'm glad you stayed.
Do you have charter schools in your district?
Yes.
That were approved by your board?
So, what was different for the approval of this charter?
I still don't, I'm not real, I understand their perception and they're entitled to their perception.
And I understand, so the contention between you as an LEA and those folks as the representatives of the charter, that doesn't bother me and I'm not surprised by that.
But if this is, because this is a successful program and these are people who have successfully been able to have these charters authorized locally.
I don't understand why there's a problem that seems to be common among these three charters
that they also could not be approved locally.
So, I suppose the question I'm asking is what's wrong with you, but that's not what I really mean.
The issue at the local level was that this is a school that's operating privately and does things like corporate restructuring without anyone knowing about it that gets found out after the fact.
And so they had opened charter schools in both Sweetwater and Grossmont's boundaries, had been told by Sweetwater and Grossmont that we think that's illegal and you have to come to us, and they said,
Too bad, we're going to stay.
And then when it became clear that that was the correct interpretation, they dropped petitions off that had different names on them and didn't disclose that that was, in fact, the plan.
And so it further
caused the board to be concerned about the lack of transparency because now the charter that they had been attempting to address for years was now calling themselves something else.
They had a development team.
They'd done a corporate restructuring.
But at the same time, they're proposing for Mary Bixby to sit on the board and be the CEO.
And she sat on the board and was the CEO of the corporation we were already dealing with.
And so, it was just a renaming, papering over of an operation that there were already concerns with that made no effort to disclose those.
We got no organizational chart.
We attempted to figure out what their organization was by publicly available information.
For example, we can't figure out how any of the development team gets paid or which corporation they're employed by from what we can tell from federal tax records.
They're all employed by Altus.
And so I don't know who's making that is who's hiring these people or who's paying for the Sweetwater development team And as you saw today several of the same people that had the same prepared speeches came to speak to you Supporting this petition that came and spoke with the same speech in support of the Grossmont petition And so we it appeared to just be a corporate effort to expand and nothing to do and paper over the prior violations that were already
in the process of attempting to be addressed by just calling it something else.
But yet being a part of the exact same network that we can't figure out who is actually controlling.
Okay.
And so for the charter, they've identified what they believe their enrollment will be.
How many students out of your LEA, are all of these students going to be coming from your LEA for this charter?
It's very difficult for us to tell.
We assume so.
You know, obviously, when they're located and operating in the boundaries, most of the ADA, most of the students do come from the district in which it's located.
But we've really struggled to figure out which students are at which resource center and which ADA goes to which of these corporations.
And they entirely control behind closed doors what the sign says and who's there and who's being employed and who's representing them.
And so it really is
very difficult to figure out because these decisions are made privately.
Okay, and I asked you that question because I already knew what that answer was going to be.
This was some of the conversation, thank you, this was some of the conversation that came up and that became really of great concern as the work was being done to develop
the board's new policy concerning the resource centers and the location of these resource centers in response to the Supreme Court decision.
It is, the state has no way and most districts do not have a way of actually tracking or monitoring
who is actually enrolled or who the teachers are actually serving among these schools just because of the way they have been allowed to operate for so long.
So that was part of the reason why I asked the question of the charter representatives if any of their teachers
work with or serve students who belong to or are attending some of the other charters.
And that's the reason why I asked the district, are you aware if all of the students projected to be part of this enrollment will be coming directly from their district?
There is a reason why I actually do believe that the chart and the information that's shown on the website is actually more accurate than this one for that reason.
Because there are students who probably do attend
or participate in these charter programs that are shared as a, I hate to use this word, but it's true, as a common resource among these three charters.
And I do believe their human capital and their employees are a common resource among these charters just because of the fact that the employment agreement looks exactly the same from corporation to corporation.
So this is going to be some of that stuff that when you approve this charter,
Just as we have had with almost every single charter hearing we've had this year, we will find out after the fact something to be of surprise to us as a board.
This is going to be a charter that you will approve that becomes our board charter along with the other two that they are managing.
And again, I want to point out what's common among all three of these charters is that these are the same charter management organizations that have been successful in approving charters at the local level.
And for some reason, there is some common factor
among these three entities that creates a problem for approval, not only by the district, but by the county office as well.
I think you should pay attention to that.
That is a very difficult thing for me to ignore.
If they want us to value their experience and their 20-something years of experience with successfully approving charters,
We need to pay attention to the fact that the county offices and the local school districts that previously approved their programs have not been able to approve the other two that we approved anyway.
And now we're asked to do the same thing for a third time.
I think that is something that has to be considered and paid attention to.
Okay, I think we're ready for a motion.
Thank you, Member Rucker, and I do think you are correct in your assumptions in many, many ways.
I really do.
Thank you.
That being said, I would move the staff recommendation.
Further board discussion?
If not, all those in favor, raise your hands.
Sorry.
I'm just going to say that I'm going to vote on the good faith of what's in front of me.
My organization on Monday had a name change after 49 years.
And today you cannot find our former name on any of our materials.
And so for me, I'm going to vote with what's in front of me because I want to believe that what is in front of me is actually how things are being implemented.
Thank you.
All right.
All those in favor of the motion, raise your hands.
Okay.
One no vote.
So it's approved with one no vote.
So we will move on to item 20, which are... State board projects and priorities.
And first of all, we need a motion to approve the minutes.
Okay, moved and seconded.
Any discussion?
No public comment.
Raise your hands if you approve.
Okay.
Minutes.
Okay, now we have liaison activities and we have a list of next generation science standards, Strauss-Williams.
I'll just say that the early implementers network is continuing to work together and there's going to be two convenings of leadership, July 27th and August 3rd.
And I'll be doing a state board update and talking with them about their work and the importance of their next step.
So, very exciting work as we really go to full implementation of our next generation science standards.
Okay, Charters Holliday-Williams.
Just did that.
CTC Strauss.
Just a quick summary, CTC met June 15th and 16th.
A couple of highlights just particularly related to our state board work.
They're doing a realignment of the admin services credential, their content and their performance expectations aligned to the standards for leaders.
And particularly I thought would be interesting is they're focusing on aligning the expectations around school leadership and the work around school climate.
and engagement of community and families.
Those particular areas really link a lot to what we've been talking about in updating leadership skills around our expectations of engagement.
So again, a lot of their work is updating and realigning, but particularly with our goals at State Board that we want leaders to be doing, it's exciting to see the alignment in the expectations of the preparation program.
Okay, CCEE, Board Member Burr is not here.
So I don't think we have anything on that.
Computer Science, Williams.
Yes, I'm going to read something so that I can be pretty quick about this.
But the entire computer science advocacy community in California and not to mention quite a few nationally have been waiting for California to take its first big steps in terms of computer science policy.
So on June 27th, Governor Brown approved a 2017-18 state budget that included funding for the CDE and the State Board to move forward with two separate but complementary activities related to expanding and diversifying student access in K-12 to computer science.
One of those activities will be the development of recommendations for voluntary computer science content standards that would provide substantive but flexible guidance to LEAs as they bring computer science into their curricula.
Toward that end, this body
This body, the State Board, yesterday approved item 13 on consent, which created the Computer Science Academic Standards Committee.
It also approved the 21 members recommended to be on that committee by the Instructional Quality Commission.
And your vote yesterday also approved the State Board's guidance to the Standards Committee for what they want to see out of that work.
This Commission is expected to begin its work in meetings in from September through January with recommendations coming to the State Board for consideration a year from now.
The second and separate activity funded in the 2017-18 State Budget was the convening of a Computer Science Strategic Implementation Advisory Panel.
The statute calls for this panel to be convened on or before March 1st, 2018 and to have recommendations to the State Board, the SPI and the legislature on how best to implement computer science standards throughout California in terms of building teacher capacity and what additional resources might be needed to have those to us by January 15th on or before January 15th, 2019.
Again, this is going to be another fast-moving effort, both of them that will be moving pretty much in sync with one another over the next 18-20 months.
This second panel, the advisory panel on implementation, will undertake the development of recommendations critical to the effective and equitable implementation of computer science in California K-12.
The panel will consist of a designated set of members,
many appointed by Governor Brown and others by the Superintendent of Public Instruction, and some by the Assembly Speaker's Office and the Senate Rules Committee.
So California is not the first state to move forward on implementing computer science education at the K-12 level, but by ensuring funding for these two separate but complementary efforts,
California standards and a strategic implementation plan, Governor Brown has in effect launched a thoughtful and thorough two-pronged state policy approach to expanding and diversifying computer science in California that will encourage and support all districts and charter schools as they make decisions about how best to bring this important new K-12 discipline to their students.
So as this work takes off now for the next 18 to 20 months, I want to thank and acknowledge the CDE leadership of Glenn Price, of Tom Adams and Stephanie Gregson, and others in the department that have been working hard to get this all set up, as well as I want to thank the Ed Tech Committee of the IQC and its chair, Dean Reese, for their good work this past year with completing all the prep work necessary for these two initiatives to get going.
As the Board's liaison to computer science the past few years, I expect to be attending each of the meetings of the Standards Committee and of the Implementation Advisory.
I'm excited to finally see this K-12 computer science work moving forward.
And I very much look forward to working with the staff and the advisory bodies over the next 18 months, as well as continuing to learn and to network within the larger state and national computer science community.
Excitement all around here.
Okay, that's encouraging.
Concurrence Commission, Strauss.
So the Concurrence Commission met on June 7th in Oakland.
Just quickly, it's the commission that coordinates the budget for the subject matter projects.
And you may or may not be aware there are subject matter projects for arts, history, social science, international studies, mathematics,
physical education, health, reading, literature, science, world language, and writing.
And we meet twice a year.
They really are doing some very thoughtful, deep work around continuing implementation of Common Core aligned activities.
We did talk about ESSA, the development of the ESSA plan and the implications for that for their work.
We did talk also about the role of leadership and because they primarily focus with teachers and the capacity and how they might help us with the leadership issue.
And finally, their budgets
small that they are were approved for the coming year.
Okay, next is CPAG, Straus-Berr.
Well, CPAG met to advise on the accountability.
So you heard the input on that.
English Learners, Ortiz-Lacombe.
Yeah, so yesterday we adopted the new EEL roadmap and policy and there will be a guidance document coming, well it won't be coming before the board, but it will be completed in September and going out to the LEAs for support on how to implement the new policy.
Environment holiday.
The Environmental Literacy Steering Committee met on May 22nd, I think it was.
We are making good progress toward implementing the strategies laid out in the California Blueprint for Environmental Literacy.
Since the committee was formed in January of 2016, we're now at the point of having raised over $8 million for the initiative.
including part of the state budget that's invested into a re-envisioning of the CREEC network, CREEC stands for California Regional Environmental Education Community.
And that work is going on right now with over 100 stakeholders being involved in this re-envisioning process of the CREEC program.
But one of the highlights of the May 22nd meeting for me was hearing from Carl Anthony, who is an architect and author and an urban and regional design strategist, co-founder of Breakthrough Communities in Oakland, who really helped us all understand the incredible importance
of environmental literacy for underserved communities.
When you think about who is first to be impacted and most to be impacted by environmental disasters such as Katrina or Flint or other pollution nightmares, it is often the low-income and underserved communities.
You've really brought that to our attention in a powerful way.
Okay, now we have the IQC.
We have maybe six of these.
IQC, ELA, ELD, Strauss.
So there's a follow-up collaboration committee that is meeting next week again on July 20th here in Sacramento at the Doubletree Arden.
And we've broken up into committees and they're just particularly for our work and the continued implementation of the literacy framework.
There's a group dealing with delivery of instruction.
There's also a work group on leadership capacity, which really will help our discussion around how do we help leadership as we continue to do instructional implementation.
So I'll be there next week along with Joanne Isken, who's chair of CPAC and was the chair of IQC.
And we'll be looking at continuing to support that work so I can bring that back as a report to September as we look to continue implementation of the framework and the instructional strategies.
IQC Health, Ortiz-Lacromme.
Thank you.
And I want to thank Stephanie Gregson for all the support.
I have not been able to attend this in person, but I am obviously keeping up to date.
The Health Education Curriculum Framework and Evaluation Criteria Committee has met twice over the past three months.
This is a passionate group of health educators excited to bring support and guidance to all educators through the health education framework.
and they have provided edits and revisions to all TKA 12 grade level chapters, assessment chapter, and the supporting health education chapter.
They will meet once again here, August 10th and 11th, and these are open meetings and we encourage the public to attend.
But if you cannot attend, please do send your written comments to healtheducationframework at cde.ca.gov.
And thank you, Stephanie, again.
Okay, IQC History, Social Science, Rucker Sandoval.
The History, Social Science Committee has been very busy since the last time we met.
The committee has already had its training to do the preparation and vetting for the History, Social Science adoption.
And they have, since the April training, the one week long training, they have now been, they have now received all their materials from the publishers and have been doing their review using the criteria.
The curriculum adoption form is scheduled for later this month, July 24th through 28th.
And so we anticipate at some point in time, by the next time we get to our board meeting in the fall, that we will be able to either identify and recommend new curriculum material for history social science or tell you what happened.
So we're very excited about that process.
And I want to again state this has been a very public, very open meeting.
And members of the public are always invited to attend the meetings for the Curriculum Adoption Review process.
And the Curriculum Adoption Forum is no different.
There will be opportunities for the public to observe and participate during the forum week in July 24th through 28th.
And it's going to be meeting at the Doubletree?
Yes, the meetings are at the Doubletree over off of Arden Way.
Okay, you're going to get a lot busier because the legislature appropriated somewhere between up to $20 million for rollout of history, social studies, and health.
Now, we don't have a health framework to roll out, so a lot of this looks like it could be used for professional development.
And so hopefully you can report next time on what you know about this and about what the money should go for and what the activities will be.
I'd be happy to take on that responsibility and bring back that report for next time.
Yeah, this money is really
the most money we've ever had for a rollout.
So... Well, there's a reason for it.
So, yeah, I'd be happy.
All right.
There's a reason.
Good.
All right.
IQC Mathematics, Rucker Strauss.
Okay.
So, I wanted to say that I had the opportunity at the invitation of department staff to attend the early math symposium that was scheduled at the Yolo County Office of Education in Woodland on June 23rd.
The focus of the day was to support on
to provide support to multiple initiatives, including the Whole Child Initiative and the Early Math Project.
In addition to the 100-plus people who had registered to attend the forum, there were 1,625 people participating online.
The keynote speaker was Dr. Megan Franke from UCLA.
Here at the board, we spend a lot of time adopting and creating and reviewing policy documents like the math framework and the early learning foundational standards.
The breakout sessions that were created and planned for the day really made the information in these documents living.
The presentations looked at multi-tiered systems of support, mathematical reasoning, developing the academic language and literacy of young children in math, and looking at novel ways to use and implement manipulatives as part of the math instruction.
It was an absolutely great day for the teachers who attended.
Their feedback was their gratefulness that the forum could be done during the summer because a lot of them made it clear if it hadn't been scheduled during the summer,
they never would have been able to attend.
I think that suggests a lot of information about how we schedule and when we schedule activities like this and hopefully it will inform the ways that we include teachers who are early learning instructors in the rollout plans we have for future frameworks as well.
So it was a wonderful opportunity and I'm very glad I had a chance to represent the board for it.
Okay IQC science.
So let me just say that the community communities of practice, both on mathematics and science.
Those are groups of about 100 educators that come from all over our state, particularly regionally and over a couple days three times a year we
build and deepen their knowledge and then also work on their follow-up activities out in the region to build capacity.
So on August 16th in San Diego, right near the San Diego airport, Math and Science will actually be meeting on the same day.
And so the idea in the first year was to deepen their community and their knowledge, but the intent in year two of the project
is to begin to plan and do more regional outreach work to expand our work.
So that's coming up and I'm going to be attending and hopefully maybe member Williams will be available as well because in San Diego.
So anyway, I was going to drive there.
Yes.
So yeah, I was going to come.
Depends on when my grandchild is born, but anyway.
So anyway, I just wanted to say that once we develop the policies, developing and deepening the professional learning and building regional support networks in our vast state are really important.
And so we have people coming from all over our state with the understanding that this is to build capacity throughout the region.
So it's a very exciting process and that's what the ELA-ELD hopefully will continue to do over time.
Thank you.
Okay.
The Joint Committee on Workforce Pathways.
Sun?
Yes.
Great.
I think this is the first time we've been on the queue to talk about.
So we are meeting for the third time tomorrow as a group.
And this is the Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee is made up of three state board members and three members from the Community College Chancellor's Board of Governors.
And the purpose of the committee is to do some talking and work on some systems alignment between K-14 with regards to career preparation.
I'm not prepared to give you a summary of our work thus far, but I will give a more comprehensive summary of where we've gone.
Mainly, it's been just looking at some information, looking at data, ways that we can share data and information.
in what currently exists out there with regards to career and workforce preparation.
Okay, then we have Special Ed and Summer School for the Arts, but Nikki Sandoval had to leave to get her plane.
I have two ones.
One, California has rejoined as a paying member, the Education Commission of the States.
This is a group, national group of governors, legislators, state superintendents, state board members.
And these are really interesting cross-state meetings and I had been invited before just to speak about California and I presented about our dashboard and then about our school finance formula, the money from the state to the local school districts at the meeting.
So, and the governor has four appointments to make in this area and the assembly and the legislature also have appointments.
Second, hopefully you'll be hearing more about this.
I met with the WASC Accreditation Association.
Again, this is, you know, Karen and I have met with them several times.
They, as you hired our former staff member, Nancy Brownell, to help them bring their accreditation policies much closer to ours.
And they produced a document that is really, I think, highly meshed with us.
So at some point, I want to make public that we have some
relationship with accreditation.
They're not over here and we're over there, the way it's been for my entire career.
So, and we will bring them in.
And I also think that we talked about as we go into technical assistance,
you know, for example, districts and schools that are undergoing WASC, that could be some part or the technical assistance for that time.
They're also moving their accreditation, you know, into elementary and middle schools by request.
They're really stepping up there.
So I hope this will culminate in some formal relationship that can be announced between
the department, the board, and the WASC.
And that would be, I've never seen another state that's quite pulled that off.
So, that would much aid our alignment policies, I think, where we're trying to align everything behind our standards and the other things we're doing.
So, those are my two reports.
And now, Board Member Sisson would like to make some comments.
I just wanted to say a huge thank you to all of the SCE staff and board members for helping me through my time here.
This was the best possible way that I could have chosen to spend my free time during my senior year.
It was really, really incredible learning about all the intricacies of the California way of education and meeting all of you influential people who have really, really shaped my life.
Education has just been so incredibly important to me and so
all the things that you do.
I know it kind of seems kind of long sometimes at these board meetings, but it really, really, really matters.
And personally speaking, it has really changed my life.
And on this, I've just learned so much about my state and the people who live here and just all these crazy things that
You know, like, it's crazy to think that our state is just so diverse, but yet we still all, you know, so many people come to Sacramento to come and speak and validate other people's opinions.
And it's just an incredible thing to be a part of.
And so I wanted to thank you all and let you know that I'll be continuing advocating for education in some way, hopefully for the rest of my life.
So thank you.
This has been a life-changing experience.
Thank you.
Okay, well that brings us now.
Oh, one more item.
I have one more liaison report to give.
I was asked to participate with the disproportionality advisory work group.
This was a, the invitation came from staff at the Department of Education.
The work group met for the first time on June 28th.
What makes this group's work important is on a regular basis, the state of California has to submit to the Office of Special Education Programs a state performance plan and annual performance report.
And California, in the time I've been on the board, has done a great deal of work to shore up its compliance with all of the multiple indicators required to be addressed in the report.
But indicator 10 has to do with a report of ethnicity by disability.
And California has an issue with disproportionality that a number of students based on ethnicity are overrepresented both in referrals and placement in special ed, particularly
students who are African-American.
The purpose of this work group is to not only examine and analyze what the root causes are, to study the state's data, to develop a set of recommendations that the state board will eventually be asked to consider and approve as part of the state's plan.
I believe Nikki Sandoval was also asked to participate with this group.
She wasn't able to attend the first meeting that was scheduled on the 28th, but I believe the work will continue going forward.
We'll meet at least three other times before a recommendation comes to the board.
So I want the board to be aware that this has been a long-standing conversation we've had with the department.
about this particular issue.
And this is the, this work group is part of the steps they've undertaken along with the Advisory Commission on Special Ed to try to figure out a way to address it.
Thank you.
And so now we're down to item 21.
This is general public comment on items that are not included on our printed agenda.
Call the list, please.
Would the following people please sign up?
Robin Goldman, Lauren Gelber, Angela Barker, Samantha Lyman, Gretchen Richardson, Kelly Murphy, Allison Wah, and Paula Connelly.
You could do a group of five and have three minutes for somebody to talk or you could share the three minutes.
Then you could have the rest of you come if you wanted another way.
I wish you guys had had some food first.
Good afternoon.
We are concerned community members in the Ross Valley area of Marin County.
At your last board meeting, we informed you of Ross Valley Charter's declining enrollment and had asked the committee to request a material revision.
Since then, the Charter's enrollment has continued to decline, and thus today we are asking you to revoke the Charter.
CDE's mission statement is to create strong, effective schools with valid accountability.
Revoking this Charter is in line with SBE's mission, as the Charter's low enrollment makes its budget unviable and its future highly suspect.
The SBE's assessment of the Charter's financial viability was based on an enrollment of 222 students.
As of June 24th, Ross Valley Charter has only 133 students enrolled.
This is a 40% drop from the 222 on which you approved financial viability.
It is inconceivable that the charter will enroll enough students to generate the necessary revenue to make their school financially viable in the next six weeks.
The majority of our community does not support this charter and thus families are highly unlikely to sign up.
Moreover, the demand at the younger grades is not enough to cover the graduating higher grades, much less increase the overall enrollment to get to 222 students.
The alleged demand for this charter has clearly not materialized.
Additionally, the charter listed in their SBE petition $80,000 as cash positive reserves.
However, from PRA requests, we recently learned that this money comes from personal loans.
These undisclosed loans, which have terms of repayment beginning next year, eliminate the majority of the charter's reserves.
We find the Charter's failure to disclose these loans to the SBE to be troublesome.
At a core level, the Charter has misled you as to its current and future budgets, meaning your approval was based on faulty information.
Additionally, in that same PRA response, the Charter disclosed that it has another 50,000 impersonal loans in the pipeline.
Can we get two minutes?
And we're, the three of us are pulling our time for three minutes.
We are here to discuss Ross Valley Charter's Prop 39 request.
The charter is not following state regulations that require notification of over allocated space.
When RVC filed the Prop 39 request, they projected in-district enrollment of 189 students.
Our district accepted this projection and provided space in the sixth grade building of our middle school.
This is the only space that met the requirements of continuous and equivalent space that would not cause major disruption and student displacement.
However, there is a high cost to placing the charter at White Hill Middle School.
Our 800 middle school students will be crowded into two buildings designed for 540 students.
Our sixth graders will lose their separate space which builds communities and a soft transition into middle school.
We will lose special ed classrooms, teacher break rooms, office space used for counseling and therapy, bathrooms and flex space.
Several teachers will lose their classrooms altogether and roam with carts.
As of June 24th, the charter had 103 in-district students registered.
This is a far cry from the 189 that Ross Valley School District provided space for.
As you've heard today, their enrollment has been on a continuous decline, yet RVC will not officially notify the district of these lower enrollment numbers.
As you know, Prop 39 policy states, a charter school must notify the school district when it anticipates that it will have over allocated space that could be used by the school district.
RVC has budgeted over $70,000 to pay over allocation fees in the 2017-18 school year, so they clearly anticipate and acknowledge this over allocated space.
Yet, they have not provided the mandatory notification.
In June, our school board voted on the recommendation of Superintendent Rick Bagley to use this over allocated space if slash when RVC provides notification.
We want and need this space.
We want to do the right thing for our middle schoolers.
It's much more important than the money.
Perhaps RVC hopes enrollment will still increase.
The state provides a 25-student buffer versus RVC's projection of 189 in-district students.
To hit this threshold of 164, the charter must increase its current enrollment by 59%.
Given enrollment declines and the short period of time until school opens, this is highly unlikely.
In the meantime, RVC is recruiting out-of-district kids in an effort to achieve financial solvency.
This was not the intent of Prop 39.
I am here speaking on behalf of myself, also the 1,500 members of our small community who signed a petition asking RVC to revoke their Prop 39 request, the 750 members of our community who signed a second petition asking them to notify the districts and take the classroom back, and the 200 members of our community who recently sent you letters asking you to revoke their petition.
The Ross Valley Charter School is receiving national attention for the impact of Proposition 39 laws on our small, high-performing school district.
Meanwhile, our district, Ross Valley School District, is bracing for the effects this charter will have on the remaining 95% of students in terms of loss of funding and larger class sizes.
We are concerned that the questions we have have gone unanswered, specifically my request for information under the Public Records Act.
Where is the accountability for this lack of response?
Ross Valley Charter is seeking to fulfill its undersubscribed program without of district students.
This is a failed experiment, which is being done at the expense of all our children.
We implore you, Superintendent Torlakson, to rescind the financially unsustainable charter, which does not have the enrollment or the support of the community.
Proposition 39 has the unintended effect of undermining the bedrock of our democracy, namely our great public schools.
Please use your authority and wise discretion to revoke this charter.
Go together for two minutes.
Hi, I'm Samantha Lyman.
I'm a Ross Valley School District parent and member of STAND.
The SBE's stated mission, Leads With, creates strong, effective schools with valid accountability.
Regarding Ross Valley Charter, I ask you to help me understand why the SBE and the CDE think this school is viable when the hard data clearly demonstrates otherwise.
Why must 2,000 students suffer, the charter and traditional students both, for a program that will not be strong or effective or even in existence this time next year?
You've taken responsibility for this charter after it was denied three times at the local and county level.
This particular school has garnered local, state, and national notoriety and serious criticism from Diane Ravitch.
I understand that the laws, the evolving laws, which were written for larger districts in need of innovation have facilitated the situation getting to where it is today.
But those same laws also provide an opportunity for the state, the CDE, to evaluate the viability of this not yet open school, which is certain to cause negative disruption.
Please reach out to your colleagues at the CDE and ensure that the school has effective oversight.
If Ross Valley Charter were here today, it would not be able to satisfactorily answer questions about viability.
All of the data, financials, enrollment, lack of staffing, presently indicates that it is unequivocally not viable.
We ask that the state exercise its authority and obligation to protect the educational opportunity for all students.
Superintendent Torlakson, I ask that when the CDE conducts its site visit prior to the charter's opening, that it looks deeply at the unsustainable financials, recognizes that the school will not fulfill its mandate and revokes the charter, thereby protecting the students who will be harmed.
Thank you.
All right.
Okay, that concludes our board meeting and the board is now adjourned until our September meeting.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, okay.
Sorry if I can be just very brief.
Terry Burns, California School Boards Association.
I wanted to call to your attention Assembly Bill 1217, which was put into print late last Friday.
It establishes an independent state-run STEM K612 school in Los Angeles County.
Our concern is that the legislature is circumventing the current processes to become its own charter school authorizer.
Well, the author specifically does not call this a charter school.
As Member Rucker stated earlier, if it walks like a duck and talks like a duck, it's not a chicken.
And this school would be operated by a non-profit organization, has access to charter school facilities funds, has only the existing charter board transparency provisions regarding conflicts of interest.
and doesn't require homeschool permission for transfer in.
So, as you know, both traditional and charter schools are operating successful STEM programs throughout the state.
We have concerns that they're creating yet another educational structure in the state.
Thank you.
One more.
Yeah, it's on.
Hi, my name is Rebecca Wu, and I worked at TRUSD as a teacher in a public school, public school, where most or most all of the teachers at the school were substitutes in unreported vacancies.
We were ghost teachers.
The district misinformed or failed to inform the CTC, the CDE, the SARC reports, the parents, and the Williams Act Civil Rights County auditors.
The district, the board, knowingly did this for at least a year because I informed them.
What I'm finding is that counties or COE, County Office of Education, around the state of California, because I've been spending hundreds of hours looking into these
issues are not looking at vacancies and misassignments correctly.
There needs to be a simple change.
The COEs need to look at all the credentialed employees and our substitutes over a period of time.
Simple and easy change.
So then this won't happen.
Megan Ellis and the SARC team have my information.
Please.
Let me talk for and get on the agenda for the future that I can go over I have extensive information and Material that I could present and recommend is that I recommendations that I could recommend for the for the County Office of Education's I don't know what kind of authority the the Thank you
All right, that concludes our meeting and board is adjourned.